And record to surf.
Got the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the fleshlight and type in
the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
Oh Shit.
That's right.
Oh God.
Damn.
And with that said,
here we go.
Bitches buckle up.
John Heffrons in the motherfucking house.
Now my girl back.
[inaudible]
what's
up bitches,
ladies and gentlemen,
the one,
the only John Half Ron has joined us.
Thank you very much.
You know I'm always conscious about how I sit here cause after I'll do your
show,
I'll get tweets that say,
I don't know,
he kind of looks like a tool just by how we sit.
So now I'm here.
I don't know who I sit with,
my posture and puffy chesty and some romance lighting up in this motherfucker.
Or,
or,
or do you sit like this?
You,
I see.
I don't even think of how you'd sit.
It's only if you have like the word industry on your shirt or something.
That's what you need to have that.
That's the key.
Why did I do,
I do have industry.
I have a,
do you think that John Heffron and August
spooky.
Now it's kind of cool on my face.
Yeah,
but yours?
Yeah.
Headphones too dark.
Can't see us winning smile and his palmated hair.
What do you use department?
I used to use whatever.
Yeah,
palm aid,
but now that company's discontinued to him.
I just have to shave it off.
Chris.
I can't find switch the crew.
I'm like,
we need like red lights in here.
This is a place it should be more chilled.
You know what I'm saying?
To more of a stoner hut.
Like right now it's like we're sitting in an office with some lights on.
It would be bad ass if it just had a couple of black lights and so everyone's
fat and life Collo some fucking velvet paintings and shit.
No,
I just,
I feel like it's,
it's just two s two normal.
You know,
this is so normal.
This room is as normal as you can get.
There's nothing crazy in here and knows a Johnny Cash picture of doing poster.
There's nothing going on in here.
This room has nothing.
Maybe.
Is it good to have nothing because then you bring your own something to it and
you know you,
you know you don't,
you're not influenced by your environment where you're not distracted,
you're not distracted.
Right.
So John,
half,
would you make it visually like blow it out with some reds and some Greens and
make it visually awesome?
How have,
how much are you really worried about these people who don't like the way?
Shit,
let's get to that.
You know what?
Yeah,
right.
I don't know why I'm confident enough in myself not to let it put for some
reason.
When you are,
anytime you're upset about something,
it's because anytime you get mad it's because there's fear.
So I think when I,
when I read those,
I go,
well yeah,
you know what?
I do kind of slouch and then,
and then I get all up in my head so I slept terrible.
I'm short as it is,
but I slumped and slumped down.
It's horrible.
Yeah.
It's bad for your back too,
you know,
it seems like a,
it's easier to do somehow and it just like to slouch but as I could,
it's really Nazi you up and shit started to go when I'm on planes.
Right.
I try to sit like the whole flight a little bit more cause I slouch crazy on a
plane because you sleep like,
like that or you can stand straight.
The more you can control your posture.
Definitely the best Atar you get like funky back thing.
I don't like it cause it feels like I'm like,
hey look at my titties.
Yeah,
it does kind of look a little douchey.
And he'd go on a little handyman at the beach.
I remember once years and years ago they had some type of Bra thing that guys
can wear that throws your shoulders back.
It is some type of yeah it so you put it on and it,
and I almost bought it.
Really?
Just kidding.
She was sexy as fuck.
You should've got that.
And then say she's hooked up with the girl and see if she could undo it with
like one hand.
Oh,
you've done this before you dirty little fat Bra sloughed.
Yeah.
What's up with those crazy outfits where they just tightened women up?
You know they have a weird outfits that you buy that like sucking your ass,
suck in your legs and there's like compression shorts.
You know I watched a whole commercial on at once when I was on mushrooms and the
funny thing is it's like they had this woman,
it was a for a thing like that word squeezed your body and make it look like you
were skinnier and had bigger boobs.
But they showed like the before and it was like frumpy boobs and I was just
thinking,
imagine the audition,
I'm looking for a frumpy boob person and imagine not getting that audition
because you were too frumpy.
Not frumpy,
not frumpy in frumpy.
One was like they had sun damage,
there was a boob hanging out out of like one part of the Bra and it was like a
mole on the other side.
Damage when even my son like you know where it has been that crazy freckled
wrinkle a look,
you know what I'm talking about.
But then they should like the after and it was just like she had her shirt on
but her boobs were really perfect.
I was like,
wait a second.
What about the mole it?
What about the sun damage?
You're just tricking me.
That's got to be discouraged.
You're going in any audition where you're going in as the before?
Yeah.
We're looking at with the for 25 35 our buddy Tony does infomercials.
Tony from Columbus,
he does infomercials and he let me in on how they do those fitness ones.
They get in shape motherfuckers and they pay him to get fat.
Oh really?
Never thought about that's what the verse,
they get these guys who are bad ass in shape dudes,
you know they're,
they're shredded and ripped and they reverse the process and then make the guy
just not work out for a while and get fat and they stand there and look all
slumpy and shit and they get paid and then they get back in shape again.
Yeah,
I know somebody that did the one that's at cvs right now where it's like a thing
you put in your water and it makes you lose weight.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's like what it does is that makes you,
it makes you not want to eat.
Like it kills your Alpha hydroxy cut or something.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
But he was paid to do this commercial because the commercials before and after,
right.
He's like,
I didn't that shit once.
All
I did was I got the money and just worked out like a motherfucker and starved
myself and that stuff so bad.
It's such a,
a weakness that people pray on and the government kind of lets them do it
because it's real hard to figure out what's causing you to lose weight.
Because I'm gonna have to do is say,
must be,
uh,
you know,
you must do it with a proper exercise and diet as well as taking this pill.
And that's all you have to say.
And no one's going to exercise,
you know,
half the people that are taking these fucking things for lazy as Shit.
We're not going to exercise.
Right.
You know,
I know a woman that was barely overweight,
man.
I mean,
she was like fucking shit.
Five pounds overweight,
maybe like a little two last cans of Coca Cola.
She didn't even say five.
Okay.
I mean,
yeah,
she was probably 10 pounds over the,
the perfect,
you know,
but she was good.
She wasn't fat and she got light bulb and I'm like,
you lazy bitch,
you're just going to go and get that stuff sucked out of you.
This is like a serious easy solution.
Just fucking eat less,
work out more.
It's that simple.
You know,
get up an hour earlier,
you know,
just fucking do,
do some crazy DVD,
you know,
30% faster than you normally walk to a gym.
You know how many fucking DVDs there are out there.
All you have to do is follow the DVD.
You need to hand weights and you follow along with this crazy fitness freak.
And next thing you know you're in shape.
You know,
it's God damn,
you know,
didn't I'll fucking hole stuffed under your skin and suck sucking fat out of
your body.
Whoa man,
that's,
that's some deep shit man.
And then you have to wear compression shorts.
You have to wear these heavy heavy shorts because if you don't that a lot of
times it doesn't smooth out good.
A lot of times what happens when you get the light pole is it leaves behind
like,
like Funky,
like meteor crater type shit.
You know,
it doesn't,
it's not all smooth like your leg,
you know?
So yeah,
it's a little thinner,
but it's all fucking weird when you touch it,
you know,
you could feel scar tissue under there,
man.
They're chewing out your body.
You Lazy cunt.
Get the fuck Jim.
Do not have any friends that have your back.
You know,
your friends should grab you and go,
Hey,
no,
don't do that.
Right that you,
you're fucking 10 pounds overweight.
You crazy bitch.
Don't get a hose stuffed under your ass and you can't do anything for three
weeks.
Can't even sit right cause your ass has been vacuumed.
You crazy hooker.
Just go to a body rock TV and do that chick's workouts.
What does that,
oh man,
it's literally the greatest website and they get paid here.
Is this page plug a plug for?
No,
I said a friend of your wives.
I have no idea who she is.
She just rushing chick.
Who's a fitness chick whose husband kill you and take your liver?
Who'd,
who shoots the workout videos as if their porn.
But they're actually really tough workout.
Okay.
I just said something there about the Russian checks gonna kill you and take
your liver.
Now if you're a Russian woman,
you'd probably say,
well that's pretty racist shit you just said yes.
But let's be honest,
there's a lot of Russian women who will kill you and take your liver.
And the reason why total.
Yeah.
And the reason why I'm bringing that up is because the last couple of podcasts
we've been talking about this Jeremy Clarkson situation.
And at first I was criticizing this comedian from making fun of Jeremy Or for
picking a Jeremy Clarkson,
cause I love that fucking show.
You get paid by top gear and then,
no,
it's one of my favorite fucking shows,
man.
I love that show.
It's,
it's fun.
I,
you know,
we talked about it yesterday with Adam Carolla,
but,
um,
so there was a dude who messaged me yesterday and he said that he was from
Mexico and he said that I had it wrong.
His name is Al Dose,Z ,
e f and a,
you know,
the way the message you sent me wasn't Douchey in any way.
He just,
he said,
I got the story wrong.
Here's The v he said to me that I personally,
me,
I got the story wrong.
Here's the video.
And uh,
um,
Saludos from Monterey,
Mexico.
So he sends me his thing.
He's from Mexico.
So I said,
all right,
well let me say,
because the thing I read before was that what he had said is there's no Mexicans
don't do well in the Olympics because anyone who can run,
swim or jump Missouri jump has already gotten across the border,
you know?
So I was like,
that's not even that bad.
Like,
what's,
what's so bad about that?
That's nothing like if you're really shitting on this guy for making that joke,
the,
you're the asshole.
It's like,
come on man.
You know there should be you,
if you're Italian guest,
what?
Shithead you're going to hear some mob jokes.
All right.
If you could give her Irish,
you're going to hear some drunk jokes.
It's not,
it's not bad.
Come on,
you can't take a joke.
That's what I thought until he sent me this and listen to this because this is
all about a Mexican sports car that they're reviewing.
Anyway,
that's,
we got a bit off topic,
but there you are.
A new Ford Focus.
Only do if you just want some car chaps.
Listen,
have you ever wanted a Mexican sports car?
Yes,
I have.
Good news because there is one and here it is and it's called the Tortilla
is not called the tall team.
Why is it useful?
I don't remember.
It's something a bit.
So you just made up the name.
I've forgotten.
Would you want a Mexican car?
Because cars reflect national characteristics.
So German cars are sort of halal build hand Italian cars,
a bit flamboyant in quick Mexican cars.
Just going to be a lazy factless flat
leaning against the fence asleep.
Looking at a cactus with a blanket with a hole in the middle on is a coat
is interesting because they can't do food the next cause it's kind of like,
cause it's all like sick with cheese on it.
How much is this Mexican sports car?
The refrig Mexican sports car is 33,000 pounds.
That isn't enough.
And I know there was,
there isn't enough because that's been somebody paid for that to be developed
and it's got to be shipped over.
It's I say tell him to quit to the Carl.
Does he say that though?
But they do say and they're blurred.
He's got rack and pinion steering.
Wow.
It's got steering.
I'm sorry,
but just imagine waking up and your Mexican,
you can just go straight back to sleep again.
Oh,
I'm going to do all day.
That's what I'd be looking at again.
He could play him about this cause the Mexican embassy,
the ambassador is going to be sitting there with a remote and so at this
they won't complain.
It's fine.
Oh,
now and tell you what,
there's a radio station in Germany.
Okay.
Offered a 20,000 quids worth of mini Cooper as a prize.
So any listener who would do the zaniest craziest thing.
Okay.
And the chipper one is when it's,
because he had the word mini tattooed on his face.
US.
That's it.
I think
that's all the shit they said about Mexicans,
but that's a big difference.
That's not just kind of joking,
throwing out a,
yeah,
we get it where this way,
you know.
Yeah,
this is an interesting subject now because uh,
this is where the line is and that first of all to say,
imagine waking up and remembering your Mexican,
the fact that they'd let that clumsy,
poorly written line just get in so they could have a wake up joke and you'd go
back to sleep.
That's what they did with that is is a writer issue that's a hate and hate.
Well,
yes.
What they're saying was hate,
but the reason why they're saying is is a,
is a very poorly written line that someone wrote for them.
It's very obvious.
That's like a shitty comic set up because he sets it up in this artificial way.
Imagine remembering waking up and remembering your Mexican,
wait,
why am I waking up?
I was asleep remembering a Mexican,
like,
wait,
what is this weird fake premise you're setting up?
Well,
it's only so that he tell this Mexican go back to sleep joke.
So what he hasn't,
he has sacrificed the feelings of an entire nation just to get to one shitty,
like wake up and go to sleep.
Joke.
That joke was terrible.
And then the other one shitting on Mexican food.
Mexican food is fucking awesome.
And you will tell me that Mexican food is nothing but sick on it.
They can't do food,
can they?
It's just sick with cheese on it.
Hall English guys are saying that.
That's funny.
That's rude shit.
And it's okay if it's funny,
but it's not funny.
You know,
it's like,
come on man,
I can't go with you.
Yeah,
it's,
it's not,
it's not enough.
You know,
there's not enough there to justify doing it.
So what you have is to offensive jokes.
One of them about food,
not that big a deal,
but the other one about,
or imagine waking up and remembering your Mexican,
like that's just straight Polack jokes.
Like that's racist.
That's,
that's,
that's spic jokes.
That's the,
you know,
anything,
anything you want that's,
that's a nigger joke.
That's like,
I mean it really is.
I mean that's,
they're doing it to Mexicans.
That's like bugs bunny Yammer from 1960 that was,
that was bad.
And then the other thing is that the taking on the characteristics of the
nation,
like the whole nation,
Rick,
really like,
first of all,
you motherfuckers have never seen Mexican gardeners.
Okay.
If you want to talk about lazy Mexican gardeners aren't lazy at all.
Their chopping
down brushes and stacking them on the top of a pickup truck with giant big
fucking doors on each side of the pickup truck to keep this overflow of
branches.
And they're polling it and tying it down.
There's a fucking hard day's work,
dude.
They're doing it every day and they're there at seven o'clock in the morning
like where they got this lazy reputation and to say a whole nation.
Yet the nation.
Here's the problem.
It's got no government.
Okay.
The government is completely missing.
It's completely,
totally corrupt.
The fucking,
the entire country is co-opted by gigantic,
militaristic gangs.
The drug lords,
I mean it's,
they literally own like giant sections of the country that they cannot reclaim.
They have massive corruption throughout the police force,
massive corruption throughout their government.
They have all sorts of problems,
but there no fucking different than you,
man.
They're just in a shitty situation.
Mexicans are the least latency as person.
I did not lazy at all,
man.
They're human beings and they're in a fucked up environment.
It's just,
it's a scientific experiment.
What happens when the environment offers no hope?
Well,
yeah.
People get to feel sad and they're fucked up and they like to drink.
That's normal,
dude.
That's normal.
That's what you would do that to you.
Fuck,
you're just lucky you're over here.
It's,
it's,
it's total racism and it's not funny.
It's like what they're doing is that,
unfortunately,
it's not funny.
I see what they're trying to do,
but what they did was ham handed.
If I was working on that show,
I would have said,
we're not doing this man.
I would have stopped him.
I would've or I would've tried.
I would've said it.
I mean,
if I was one of those guys,
that was the joke that I was supposed to deliver,
I would say no way.
I go,
you need to stop and think about what you're doing to get out a few Mexican
jokes here.
You know,
that's all you're trying to do and you,
you,
you know what you're saying is not funny.
Like saying that every good Mexican has swam,
ran or jumped over the board.
That's a joke.
Cause there's a border and we all know they want to get across the border.
And that's why Mexico doesn't do well in the Olympics.
That's how it's kind of fun.
And every Mexican comic jokes about that kind of plays into that.
That's kind of funny.
But when did you start going,
imagine waking up and remembering your Mexican?
What the fuck man?
And that's a very unfortunate to me because like I said,
I love that show.
I mean,
and he says a lot of offensive shit,
but it's always very tongue and cheek very,
he's coming from this snooty British way of looking at things and yeah,
that way I enjoy it.
I enjoy his son joined a snootiness cause I even know don't like that Richard
Hammond guy right there.
That was bad.
And I usually like him a lot.
You see it as great on the show.
You see his demeanor when he was saying that joke teller,
he was like looking at his glass like Ah,
these are gonna have to wake up to the Mexican.
Like it was just like,
I just wanted to slap him with.
Unfortunately it was a performance,
and this is what I'm Anna Crowe was talking about to us yesterday.
The difference between how Adam handles it and how they handle it as Jeremy
Clarkson,
they write everything out.
Everything they say is scripted and they write it out and rehearse it and do it
out.
So that was like him trying to get out this joke.
Instead of him talking from the heart,
which is what Corolla does when he does his rants,
you know,
he comes from the heart,
just he's not,
you know,
I mean he might repeat the same thing over and over again,
but that's just because that's what he means and that's what is in his head.
And he's just going to say it again.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not like some calculated nonsense.
And what these guys are doing is trying to get out some calculated nonsense and
he's trying to get it out with the most impact possible.
That's also because they're doing it in front of a live audience and a live
audience of people standing up,
which has got to be annoying as fuck a plus.
If you're reading a script,
they're just delivering your line.
It is at face value.
You're making up stuff from,
or use an Improv heart.
You have a filter system,
right.
You know,
even when you're B,
you know,
you run it through a filter going,
yeah,
how does this sound?
I can make this funny.
Yeah.
But that one,
I mean if you like say if you were on a show or you're a accomplished standup
comedy,
did you win season one of last comic standing or season to season to season two
motherfucker,
he's legacy last comic standing champion,
all those bow before him.
So you've got,
you know,
I mean you've got a reputation to uphold if you are on that show and all of a
sudden they wanted you to deliver a line like that,
what would you know you put your foot down,
right?
Yes.
I had to do that.
I was on um,
uh,
Tony Rock project.
Do you know Chris's brother?
Yeah,
he had a,
he had a show.
Very funny.
Super Nice Guy.
And I was at your show and I was,
I was the,
the white cohost on the show.
So it was Tony Rock and me.
You are the wacky white guys.
Yeah,
he would give me a lot of lines like,
you know,
like a rap battle that I'm a guy who doesn't know what a rap battle lists and
and I would contact go and I grew up with like Ronnie,
I know what a rap battle lists.
I was a kid from the 80s I know more about kind of wrapped then a lot of young
guys do,
cause I was old school,
we could go UTFO and
we do a lot of that.
Like I'm the dumb white guy stuff.
I didn't get upset and I would say,
can we say it a little bit smarter so I don't come across as,
but you're doing a character when don't come across as a retarder if it's
funnier.
Wow.
The guy didn't run.
No,
it wasn't like I was me,
but it's what I mean.
Is it John Heffron?
I think I was,
yeah.
Yo Dude,
you got to come off as a real retarded.
You can't catch it.
No,
I want to go over with you.
Fuck yeah.
News radio.
It was a total retard.
Nope,
no I wasn't.
I was host show Garelli my whole character on news radio was the guy who was an
idiot savant.
I was half retarded,
you know.
But I knew stuff about like how to my fucking fix elevators and shit and rig
computers and make stun guns out of garage door openers and stuff.
Conspiracy theory.
But this one,
I wasn't playing a character.
I was just John had for introducing the,
the skits.
So I understand.
So you were playing your me.
Hey Tony Rock.
Hey I'm John Hubbard.
You know John,
we went on the streets of that still really streets.
Did you guys make cakes?
I mean,
you know,
like that type of,
I'm a white guy,
you know,
I'm like Carlton Fresh Prince,
right?
Cause that's,
and that's a different story because even though you should go with the joke,
what's going on,
the funny thing is gonna make you,
you know,
whatever makes you the most retarded.
But that's you really playing yourself.
Like what if they're just calling you an idiot?
You know?
And it's Kinda like,
you know,
it's like what a black guy gets on stage and goes,
hey,
why I'm out here.
All my friends are out stealing hubcaps and I always go,
rarely,
rarely.
You're going to laugh at that.
Really we're going to how the war,
the worst is when,
yeah,
I ain't seen this many white folks since my trial.
Yeah.
We don't have any guys who he's heard do that joke.
We were doing that.
I was talking to a comic can.
We were doing automatic applause breaks cause this one guy had like everyone you
could possibly have in his act.
Like you know what?
Single moms that really have a tough job.
Clap,
clap,
clap.
You know what?
Our troops are over there.
Clap,
clap,
clap.
Whoa.
That's a specific type of Greg set up that black guys do.
Black guys when they're in trouble we'll go give it up for the ladies.
Y'all get up to the ladies.
Ladies,
ladies,
ladies got it hard out there y'all.
A lot of single mothers.
A lot of single mother,
but much love.
My mom raised me single.
Yeah,
no.
So anyway,
what's up?
So am I drinking?
What am I drinkers?
They drink.
He bonds with us.
We drink.
Yeah.
There's a little of that going on and unless you're really setting something
really strong up,
it's not really,
they can off state.
Yeah.
It hits with the one,
two,
three.
You know,
it's a trick.
I mean a lot of guys have tricks in their act,
you know,
and some tricks are good though.
So I'm trying to,
so some are like impressions,
impressions are tricks,
but I like impressions if someone is good,
you know,
I like hearing like Jame or do like Christopher Walken,
Casey Kasem.
If I listened to it,
I could do Casey case.
You know,
if I really listened to him like,
like I could do Joe Diaz,
this voices that I can do and there's horses I can't do.
I'm not like,
like what's his name?
Frank.
Kellyanne.
Dalia Endo.
That guy can do,
he can he nails motherfuckers.
He's a,
he's got a a but Freddy Lockhart man.
He's a bad motherfucker to that.
Morgan Freeman and the ice tea.
Those are,
those are,
yeah.
He was on your show.
A couple pie.
He was good.
I could use to be on Caliendo show toe.
Alright.
I can do bad impressions of people doing impressions.
Like I need one person removed.
Like I kept checking we're doing Tracy Morgan but I can't do Tracy Morgan.
How bad is Vegas?
Kelly Endo was making fucking ridiculous money there.
And he said,
no,
I don't want to do it.
Yeah.
Done.
I can only live right next to Satan's balls for so long before the smell and the
funk and the fucking you're living in Satan's ball sweat,
fog.
I don't know if you guys talk about that kind of stay stay on point.
Did you see that a Canadian comic?
We haven't talked about that.
That got fine.
That got sued.
Yeah.
What did he get sued for?
How much?
What the $22,000 Antia perform.
Can't perform in Canada.
How long what happened?
He was on stage and make camp before my candidate got like banned.
He likes,
yeah.
Yeah,
sure.
I think so.
Yeah.
He got some,
what happened?
He was on stage and he was being heckled and uh,
two ladies through wine.
Adam like,
you know,
like tossed it,
right and then you start,
you're saying,
you know,
shut up you lesbians.
And he started,
I don't know what his exact,
but he was like,
you two lesbians,
are you going to go home later?
And then they lot harder than that.
He called them dykes and cons.
They shoot him for 22,000,
500 bucks.
Was that the total they sued them,
sued them for feelings.
Hurt for slander,
for,
for him calling them names from the state.
What they won.
She won one for her feelings awarded the mode.
That feeling,
that opens up a whole.
So now as a comic,
what you have to do is you literally have to read a disclaimer,
but by you shouting at me,
you are saying that I have to like,
you know,
you're going to have to have some card carry read before you make fun of the
guy.
That's scary as fuck.
Yeah,
that's completely ridiculous.
Just like an opening comic like you,
you,
it was hope for Joe.
And he has like,
you know,
you're just like living on the couch at somebody's house and you,
you say something crazy,
you get sued and then now you owe $22,000 and you're not allowed back here.
But think about it.
Hecklers can shoot hecklers if you hurt their feelings.
Like there's,
I don't know that,
that can't be legal competent.
How many clubs need to have releases?
See,
bullshit shit
is what it is.
It is a bunch of fucking babies that are in charge of side it.
This gets paid what and who wins?
What?
Here's the deal,
man.
It's real fucking simple.
Come to a comedy show.
If you do not enjoy it,
leave.
If you want to talk about how you don't enjoy it online,
feel free to do so.
That's what the Internet is all about,
man.
You know,
email your friends,
put it up on Twitter or John,
John,
John Heffrons socks,
Joe Rogan fucking ate it and whatever.
Do whatever you want to do,
man.
That's all well and good.
But when you interrupt the show,
you are not just interrupting the show for the performer.
You are interrupting this show for every other fucking person in the room and
you haven't made a poll.
You haven't walked around and said,
hey,
how many of you guys would like me to yell out?
Right?
Right now,
you know,
and you know,
even then they wouldn't be honest with you because he like,
who is this crazy person asking me?
Yay,
I do what you want to do man.
And it's,
it's amazing how one,
hold on a second.
My point is that there's fucking 300 other people in that room and any person
that thinks they're more important than a show,
they're,
they're more important than the 300 of the people that person's account and they
shouldn't get shit.
And the fact that this weak ass court systems set this up and let this go
through.
That's fucking pathetic,
man.
That's fucking pathetic.
You know?
I mean that's a,
that's some kangaroo court shit right there.
That's what that is.
That's nonsense.
You can't call someone a fucking dyke when someone stops a show in hackles.
And it fells whine at you by that.
By the way,
if she a dike,
yes,
she was there with her girlfriend.
Yeah.
Okay.
Look,
you're a dyke.
That's wrong.
I have to take a quick fuck and I'm prove that you're not a lesbian dice called
themselves dykes.
Is that,
is that a bad thing?
is that,
is that fuck I could bury though,
Joe.
It's terrifying.
It's terrifying in how fucking dumb people are.
This is a person who committed a crime.
You violated the show.
You should be kicked out.
They should fucking take you and take a picture of you and never let you back in
the club again.
There should be a big fucking built bulletin board filled with pictures of
Douche bags who get drunk and yell stupid shit out and
interrupt the show for hundreds of other people and make that perform or
recognize that you're there and interact with you against his will.
Unless the guy comes up to you and starts talking to you and asking you
questions,
laugh or don't laugh.
Those are your two options.
You know,
when you want to interject your own shit and they were a preplanned routine and
material,
you're just being a cunt.
It's that simple.
And the fact that this,
this court system is paint conc like Whoa,
that's,
that's pathetic.
I think these comedy clubs need to take responsibility and make them sign
releases.
Then two,
before they showed work,
you know,
we're not,
we don't need more paperwork.
We need gut judges at fucking get it til that happens.
Dealt with,
do you want to be sued next week if you can in a heckler fight.
I don't think you can do it.
Actually have,
I actually have insurance errors and omissions insurance.
Oh cool.
Private insurance too.
But yeah,
I should get stuff like that.
But that's cool.
I didn't know that exact as I gender norm got sued and he sent me hip to it.
He got sued.
But Jim,
Jimmy went after some guy on the radio and belittled him and crushed him.
And the guy was a lawyer and the guy,
um,
and him had gotten into a lawsuit and you know,
even though,
you know Jimmy didn't lose the lawsuit,
just paying for the legal fees and everything is a huge pain in the ass.
And he said,
you know,
so he,
he sent me hip to errors and omissions stuff,
but like,
it's just ridiculous that you have to do with man,
there's only one reason I'm talking to you at a comedy club is one reason.
And that's because you yelled out something stupid.
If you're a nice person and I talked to you,
if you're a nice person,
I'm going to be nice to you.
You know,
if there's something going on,
like you're just like a peacock and I have to address it,
you know,
the,
you know that it's going to be fun.
I'm not going to be a mean person.
I'm not,
it's,
I want you to have a good time.
That's what we're all here for.
When someone's yelling something out,
you're interrupting the show.
You fuck.
You know,
and people think like,
Oh man,
or help do hope to hope show bro.
And there's always two ways you can do.
They can either ignore the guy and go,
okay,
if he responds or shouts something twice and I don't say anything,
maybe that thing will click on in his head going,
okay,
he's not going to talk to me.
But what happens is,
is you have two people,
let's say,
or one guy being a Douche.
It'll,
it'll affect 60 70 80 people around them because they keep staring at that
person because the guy,
I'll keep talking and interrupts the cancer.
You have to,
yeah,
you have to address it.
If you don't address it,
it ruins shows.
I've seen it happen many times.
There's girls and last time I was in Texas at Austin,
at the cap city,
which I love,
great club.
So one of the rare times I had to kick a whole table full of girls out,
they just,
no offense ladies.
Statistically though it's girls in their twenties early twenties that are direct
typically.
And you can look it up and you can take me to back to that.
It's always young girls.
Didn't you get video of her complaining outside saying that she was getting no,
you didn't do it.
Horse did.
Dave did.
No,
I got some of it too.
Oh,
Dave got the girl saying she was gonna Sue.
Sue and I got this crazy bitch was saying she was going to say they wouldn't
stop or turn me whatever the fuck.
It was always something was JC gain gain.
They kept fucking charming.
It was just a table full of man.
It was terrible.
There was a a fresh road kill and they were all squawking.
Every time a car went by,
it was fucking terrible,
man.
It,
it wouldn't stop and I kept telling them,
guys,
you can't fucking just talk.
This isn't a nightclub.
This is the fucking,
there's a show going on like I got to concentrate.
I'm going to do this.
These people are here to see it.
They're not here to listen to you talk.
Okay,
we cool.
We cool.
All right.
That's it.
You got to go.
Yeah,
I kicked them all out.
Edward people think it is a comedy once.
Once you start,
are you telling the story?
It's like interrupting a singer mid now your train of thought is stopped and
you're like,
wait,
what was I?
And that's why some people tried to do it on purpose.
Like guys,
you see guys doing that on purpose all the time.
The week guys,
you know,
we'll,
we'll heckle and then you go.
I'm sorry sir.
What are you saying?
What book?
Like they'll say something back to you like stupid.
Like does compensation nonsense,
nonsense word.
Like not a real conversation.
Like,
Oh,
you're just being annoying.
That's a beauty I've done.
Stand up for what,
23 years.
And when you're a young guy,
Yo,
you always have like a heckler line locked in your brain.
And if somebody says something,
you slam them and you're like,
hi,
I totally slammed.
But then you reach a point of being comfortable where you're like,
you know what,
Heckler Guy,
you bore me.
You can leave here.
So you can just go,
I'm going to,
I'm going to hang out with the adult chicken amount as the best every he has
like his ass,
his paddle.
Yeah.
As much as people love those youtube clips that are up of hecklers getting
destroyed,
it's the way better just kick him out of the fucking show.
I want everybody to have fun,
man.
I want some one needy ass hole in.
A lot of them are want to be,
a lot of them are wanting to be comedians.
A huge percentage of them,
they think they're good.
They think they can do it,
you know,
and they just never had the balls go to an open mic night or something like
that.
But you know,
they see you and they were fucking drawn her 400 query.
I can do it too.
Or fucking queer.
I'm going to fucking ruin them on a ruined once we're headphone show night and
ruined them all the whole right there.
They're thinking,
here's what I'm going to say.
I'm probably just going to say like the last person that,
uh,
was um,
bragging about fucking up a Heckler was Dana Dear Armand,
bragging about just crushing Mike Young and she heckled Mike Young and jacked
him.
John was the one person that we know that,
uh,
stopped his show.
Mitch show to take a piss break.
Remember we talked about this a couple of weeks ago,
like Oh,
your comedy show.
That's right.
Yeah.
I still has the most of the craziest thing I've ever heard.
You know,
you might have like a,
like a bladder problem,
like my homie Mike Goldberg,
listen to this folks.
Here's a little inside information.
If you ever listen to the UFC and you know how the fire walk ups are,
you know like a dude's will come out and the music will start playing and then
I'll go hailing out of Reno,
Rockport,
Illinois.
Right.
You know this guy's a Jujitsu fighter is a,
you know,
one of the best one available that if you only hear me talking,
it's cause my goal,
birds pain.
Cause Mike Goldberg,
no bullshit.
We'll p five,
six times during a show that has he got that shit checked out.
Oh Dude.
I don't know man.
I think his deck is just broken and all kinds of ways.
I don't know.
I tried to tell him about it.
I'm like Homie,
whatever.
They got you on.
That shit ain't working.
And he's like,
it's just drinking all these red bulls because he drinks a ton of red bulls.
When we do a,
I stopped trying to keep up with him because a nice tasty red bull.
I know a cold one.
They got him in there in a bucket filled with ice.
It seems like,
you know,
and the guy goes,
you want another red bull?
I could just have a red bull whenever I want man,
when I'm at work,
you know,
sometimes like give me another one.
And then I realized,
Holy Shit,
I've drank three red bulls,
my hearts ready to break out of my fucking chest.
I'm sitting there,
I'm gone.
And like people who've said,
you'd be like,
dude,
you're a coke when you do the UFC.
No,
but yeah,
three red bull realizable man.
You might as well be on coke.
The energy you have to have because as,
as energetic as people are on TV,
that gets toned down by the time you see it.
So if you have to have crazy over the top energy for it to seem normal energy.
If I'm a guy on my couch,
man,
I guess I don't think about it like that.
I think I'm better off with one red bull then with three
excited for no reason,
but I only get excited and naturally I never tried to ramp it up and people
don't believe that.
They think that I like hype up fights.
And if I don't think much about a fight,
man,
it'd be pretty fucking flat about it.
I mean,
I have to do my job about it,
you know?
But it was some fight where I'm like,
mom,
this is not that exciting to me.
I,
I'm not,
I don't get hyped about it.
If you hear me hyped about something,
it's 100% legitimate.
You know,
I,
I don't like,
like tried to put out all this energy.
That's just how I feel about shit.
The PN one had a point when I started in on this rant.
Uh,
we were talking about me being on stage.
No,
no,
no.
Mike Goldberg's broken.
That's what it was.
So this is how you know if you're ever watching the fights and you only hear me
talking for a long period of time,
that's cause Goldberg's pin.
That's what it is.
Always.
You sure?
Yeah.
So when you hear that it's the new rules,
you got to do a shot.
So when you hear just the new UFC drinking game,
when when when a fighter's walking up and Goldberg's not talking to a shot
and it counts for Facebook fights to,
cause all of them are going to be on Facebook.
Now.
This one that's in Canada this weekend,
paper view is an hour earlier and all the PR,
all the prelims,
100% of them are going to be on Facebook.
Wow.
We're going to air all the,
and then you're gonna see is Facebook and then spike TV and then the UFC pay per
view.
Facebook.
It's going to be the shit.
All the unaired prelims.
A lot of great fucking fights and it was prelims man.
You know,
that's what,
when you get to see these guys,
like a lot of times when you see a guy and he's in the main card for the first
time RDC and homeboy fight like three or four times like I know what's up,
you know,
I know what he's,
this is like this,
this guy's awesome.
Wait,
wait.
Do you see this guy?
You know and you get,
you get a really chance to see these upcoming dudes.
You know like some guys like in name you like a hunter s Thompson and a Nixon
had a conversation once in the back of a limo and this is how a hunter s
Thompson knew that Nixon was a real football fan.
Cause he started talking about like second string quarterbacks from some obscure
college,
you know?
And he was like wow,
this guy is like legit.
Like he's a legit football fan.
You know,
if you're a UFC guy,
like UFC fans like to be like legit too.
They like to know do to fall on the undercard.
And by the way,
I made a mistake yesterday cause we've got two blasted and we were talking about
Greg Nelson,
uh,
the trainer at a Minnesota and I,
I just didn't think I was trying to like scramble and remember who fighter was.
And I was thinking about Jacob Volkman is one of them.
And uh,
Jacob Volkmann's up fucking awesome grappler.
I love watching that guy fight.
And the other guys,
nick the Carny Lense who won his last fight,
not private citizen,
but he went by Guillotine.
He's another badass fighters.
These guys are like some serious wrestlers that they're converting into MMA
fighters.
But that Greg Nelson Guy,
he does a bad ass job.
So I had made a mistake yesterday.
I wanted to correct that so that,
those two things,
I want to correct that Mexican top gear thing.
And the,
uh,
by the way,
I speak wrestling in high school.
They're getting rid of the figure four around the head.
Really?
He can't do that in high school.
I figure four around on random facts out.
Yeah.
I remember you put a chicken wing in and then you'd run it and then you'd figure
for the guy's head.
That's a dark,
like a dark.
What with your legs?
All with your lecturer.
But that,
that moves.
Now we illegal and I only know because that was the worst wrestler in my high
school history.
And I got figured for probably more than anyone in history of high of Michigan
Wrestle.
Know why.
But dudes are probably turned it into triangles.
I bet there's kids that are Jujitsu guys that are on the bottom and locking guys
up and triangles and pinning them cause they're unconscious.
That's what Dave Schultz,
who's to do the Dave Schultz and I'm,
and I'm Mark Schultz.
The Shults brothers were these fucking bad ass wrestlers.
And uh,
one of the moves they did was the Shults headlock.
And it's the same thing that Matt Hughes to,
to Ricardo Alomeda.
He got him in his front headlock and choked him to sleep with it.
And the hue,
the Hughes Right.
Pulled it off.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a wrestling submission.
Yeah.
And Hughes did it to Alomeda and now made it,
didn't even know it was coming and he's a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu.
But these,
uh,
the Schultz brothers used to do it and choke guys unconscious and then put them
on their back and they'd be pinned,
you know?
Yeah.
You pen the fucking put you to sleep first.
It's a totally different sport you're playing.
You know,
he would break guys arms with rolling Camorra's.
He would grab Camorra's and rip guys arms apart when they would take him to the
ground.
Full blast,
grab in a wrestling match.
There's like him in the Olympics.
He got disqualified for ripping some guy's fucking arm apart.
I mean,
he's like the wrestling,
but he's not wrestling.
He's trying to break your shit,
man.
Did you see that video of that kid is for your wrestling?
It's about nine years old as a Mohawk,
like chocolate l and he's eight or nine years old in the Vegas.
Kids are twins Max.
No,
this is just the unknown wrestling kid.
Oh yeah,
I did see that.
And she goes out there.
He's got my mean his fucking face like the kid.
And it's funny the comments,
all these people go,
he's too nasty.
His parents should cause he knows Jujitsu and I think in judo,
well his wrestling ridiculous talk is incredible.
He's amazing.
He's so good.
What's the youtube video then?
I would look up nine year old killer wrestlers that it has a Mohawk and you
could see as the kid walking out there,
you see every little kid that he goes to Russell like look back at his parents
going,
oh I want to go home.
I want to play soccer at one in the kitchen.
Not Fair.
Because there's other kids who are just like just starting out and this kid has
been doing it every day for years and he's got fucking some serious technique
man.
Yeah,
it's interesting you see the common future when you see the people going to,
you know,
yelling at the parents and you're being a pussy,
combos.
Those parents,
they've never been in a,
in a combat sport themselves.
It's that simple.
You need to know that somebody like that out there.
Okay.
Do you want to be like that guy or do you want to let that guy dominate you like
that?
Those are your two choices.
Do you want to like have fastest sport or do you want to be like that
motherfucker?
That's the top of the rainbow.
The see it.
That's what,
that's what it is.
There you go.
Now you know,
go wrestle him.
Find out what's up.
Boom.
Yeah,
you got fucked up,
right?
Okay.
How do we not get you fucked up?
But you got to learn how to wrestle like that guy right now.
You know you have like something to aspire to the meanwhile they'll have,
they'd be happy shit if their kid was the one kicking ass parents,
man,
we gas bitches raising some soft motherfuckers besides following high school
wrestling,
which is something I noticed these cargo
and can we get the bachelor?
Watch the guy with one leg,
I forgot his name.
He was pretty bad ass.
Giant national.
Did you know that John created this really cool plugin for,
for like your Internet browser.
So like if you're like talked about this on the way over here.
So tell it,
tell us about the c suite.
You,
you,
what did you use?
You came up with the idea and he got a piece store you want to know.
Do you want me to,
I didn't know if you want me to tell that when I was in Columbus when I actually
had to go on stage
your browser,
I did a,
I was working on with this guy and he gave me some off the shelf,
uh,
like,
like energy type of weight loss type thing to work out with,
have something like that.
But I would speed mother fireworks show thirsty.
Like so in between shows I drank,
you know,
in the greenroom bottles,
maybe six bottles of water,
like just pounded them.
And then I even told the comic Cagle I've never been this thirsty in my entire
life.
I peed right before the show,
one of those long,
huge piece get on stage.
I'm on stage maybe six minutes and I start going,
I have to pee again.
Now we've all had that where I'm like,
Nah,
I'll be able to,
hey guys,
I'll,
I'll say up here for about 45 minutes so I can,
and I have to pee now.
The only thought in my head is I have to pee.
So I look at the girl in the front row.
I'm like,
so what do you do for a living?
You know,
I'm sweating now.
I'm trying to talk this.
Oh,
Brian was there,
was there while you were in the crowd,
right.
So I'm like,
what do you do?
And she talked to me,
it's,
you gave me your answer.
And I couldn't read for $1,000.
I couldn't tell you what she said.
Sweats coming off and what you are.
I literally go,
I've never had to do this in my life.
I have to go to the bathroom.
I can't even view are there.
How come he was in the crowd?
I was in the crowd,
he was just in the crowd,
just happened to be in Columbus that we can get with in town called.
And I'm like,
dude,
I'm gonna come see you.
Oh,
that's so fun.
And with crazy.
He kept on asking the opening comics.
They help who just bitter that that he's opening for me and I'm like,
I go,
can I get the mic back up here?
I have to go to the bathroom and then I would do a bit and then a couple minutes
later I go,
seriously,
I need them see you to cup.
And then he slowly walks up.
So the Columbus Comic Club,
you have to run all the way in the back room.
It all the way to the Front to pee.
So I sprint off.
I think Brian has footage of me running past them as fast as I can.
Right.
And maybe 20 guys got up to go to the bathroom when I go,
I'll be right back to them.
Yeah.
By time I get to the
bathroom,
there's 20 guys deep in the urine.
That's because a real comedy club has a fucking bathroom for the comment.
Then I,
comedy club has a bathroom in the green room and she just went out back in the
kitchen.
Can I take cuts in front of,
and this guy as he's painting with his Dick is Andrew's goes,
oh,
sorry bro.
We just thought that it would be a good time to go if you were going literally,
and he pulls away the part to see you can't land back on the Shitty way that
club is designed.
That's stupid as fuck.
There's no green room.
They're either,
it's always so embarrassed.
Like I was so to this day,
now before I go on stage,
I think I go to bathroom 15 times.
Like in my head I'm like,
nobody goes more than Goldberg and couldn't believe it.
He goes and like,
it's a running joke with the all the aren't,
you know what?
I'm going to do this UFC.
Okay,
this one,
I'm gonna do this.
UFC,
I'm going to cold,
have a video camera set up so that it'll be right there.
Might not like every time,
every time he gets up,
I'm going to,
I'm going to videotape him going to the bathroom just so we can get a number or
you mean,
you mean sitting by you?
Okay.
I'm going say in the bathroom.
I came in,
Andy Dick drinking red bull,
him in the bathroom and he,
Dick went off the wagon again.
Remember how Andy Tech was telling us,
you know,
he was talking about whether or not he yet,
I don't know if he wants this advertised,
but Ari Shaffir already let it out to me,
so I'm sure he's told other people or it's got a big fucking mouth.
Arguer could you see a code word like of Goldberg's bathroom and you go whoa,
this next fighters like light on his toes.
Like light on it.
It's bananas,
bananas and beating Banana.
No,
no.
It would have to be something like try to program the UFC.
Yeah.
Oh,
sniff.
Go.
Okay.
No,
you know what I'm saying?
If you're playing,
if you're playing the UFC drinking game,
take one shot.
Yeah.
That's what everybody would be like.
What is he talking about?
And then they'll glow.
I'll totally do that.
Yeah,
I will.
If I remember another shot,
I have to remember if you're playing the UFC drinking game,
this is,
this is one shot folks.
Yeah.
And that's another shot.
And then what?
Yeah.
And by the way,
folks,
if you're going to take some UFC drinking game shot,
make it Jack Daniels,
which is why you fucking around with some fruity tasted nonsense.
I am a big fan of the Jack Daniel shot because of Jack Daniel's shot.
Lets you know exactly what the fuck you're getting into when you do a shot of
Jack Daniels and your whole body goes,
ah,
Jack Daniels makes your fucking toe straightened out.
Sheila too.
Man.
Tequila can,
but it's gotta be cheap,
Shitty Tequila.
Jack Daniel's always gets me if I have a choice.
But there's something also about Jack Daniels.
It makes me think of like fucking Merle haggard and Johnny Cash and write down a
trail somewhere.
You know,
Dick,
with all your clothes tied to the end,
walking on the railroad tracks only about a shot of Jack.
You know,
you're all doing this together.
You like to go and you,
where are you ready?
All right,
let's do this.
You're all doing it together.
Yeah,
it's going to feel great to get a little buzz on,
but it's also,
you're all just drinking his fucking vile poison.
You're saying?
Yeah,
I know.
I'm not going to live forever.
I'm taking care of myself as well,
but every now and then the train's got go off the track and then the woods.
Here we go,
bitches,
boom,
and then when you throw the bottle against a brick wall,
it doesn't look the same as like a Zima.
I watched.
It reminds me of Mike Young.
What?
Mike Dung.
He's the one that always drink Jack Daniels,
remember?
Oh No.
He had a joke about Jack Daniel's.
That's why he had a joke about Jack 10 just makes you want to fight your
relatives.
It was that like it was a good impression.
Mike Young talking to her and play,
hey mo,
her mo zones with stone up calling her,
you know?
Yeah,
I'm might and some new material,
mumble,
mumble artists and mumble.
When he does his podcast,
when he does the podcast,
he's pretty pretty clear what's up with that.
Talk to that mother fucker on the phone.
Sometimes you want to spank him.
You want to go,
hey dummy,
how about you talking and some noise.
That sounds like words you fuck.
I think I hearing them come out of your mouth is lazy cunt.
And he's like,
well there's car Taco.
I think I agreed and more things that he says to me just because I don't know
what he says and I'm just like,
yeah,
yeah I don't have a single friend who I have more frustrating conversations with
Ari.
I'll have conversations with him on the phone.
I'm like motherfucker,
I don't know what you're saying.
You speak English and I don't know what you're saying.
This is ridiculous.
It's not another person I talked to this like this.
I have people that I'm talking to all the time that don't speak English.
I know a Russian dude barely speaks English.
I can communicate with him better than I can with Ari.
Absolutely mirrors or mumble,
mumble,
mumble.
And the worst is when he's stoned because he has stone thoughts.
And then so you add that to mumbling.
So it's like we were my friend or my hands on far.
Jesus.
Yeah,
sometimes
I used to mumble a lot.
I used to mumble when I did a newsradio like am I acting,
cause I was consciously trying when I was doing news radio to be as non actory
as I could.
I want it to be as non sitcommy.
I just wanted to be this dude who's just like a little fucking dance and stupid.
But every now and then comes up with some brilliant shit,
some fucking Weirdo.
Right.
So I would try to do it like real kind of relaxed and in doing so I would,
you know,
and trying not to be like big and fake,
I would,
a lot of times it's like it'd be hard to understand what the fuck.
I would say.
Like we'd have to do retakes.
Sometimes producer Paul stems would come over and go,
hey mumbles or to get this right.
And we're going,
oh yeah,
sorry.
So I know what it's like to get into the habit of mumbling.
But with Ari it's almost like some sort of a psychological block that he's got
going on because we've talked to him about it a hundred times.
I think I too lazy to move his mouth.
That's what I think it is a part of it.
Because when he's on stage I go,
Yo Dude,
listen to me right now.
People don't know what the fuck you're saying.
I go cause I know what you're talking about and I don't know the words you're
saying.
Right.
Okay.
And I know the premise,
I know the bit,
I've seen that bit 20 times.
I know the bit and I don't know what you're saying.
Like you got to clean up your fucking words,
man.
And remember what else he used to do.
I don't know if he does it as much anymore,
but the thing he,
from the comedy story,
when I first met him,
what I always told him,
he was like,
dude,
you breathe into the mic out of his nose.
Used to rapper the mic.
Yeah.
I used to do it like a rapper.
He used to cover the topic like this.
And
people do a lot of shit in the early days of comedy to make themselves feel
comfortable.
You know,
they're,
they're not really comfortable.
I just suck.
And it makes,
they make,
they have a,
an affectation,
you know,
they,
they add something to their natural way of behaving on purpose,
to try to be more comfortable on stage.
And it usually works the exact opposite way.
You know,
we've seen a lot of comics have pro try to pretend in their coolest fuck none.
I'm going to fuck.
But they do give a fuck.
It's the worst thing you could say when you give a fuck is I don't give a fuck.
Because then I'm like,
oh well I can't trust anything you say because all my instincts tell me you
clearly give a fuck right now and you're nervous.
You can't just be honest about your nervousness.
You fucking Weirdo.
You're not even asking for compassion.
You're so bad ass.
You don't need it.
You don't give a fuck.
Right.
You know,
it's,
it's a tricky thing,
man.
The,
the relationship that you have with the audience,
you know,
do you ever,
you mean you've,
I've been in this situation before and I assume you probably have to where you
are in the middle of a job,
but you're not really feeling this joke and not really thinking this junk and
even though you're saying it right,
it is not working at all.
Yeah.
There's a weird disconnect.
I do that with crowds sometimes it's to make you have 500 people.
You're telling a story.
Then as you're talking,
you're like,
I don't fit.
I don't,
I just don't,
I don't feel like talking about that.
And then so then your energy level goes from here to,
and then I went,
walked into the bar.
You know,
you just,
you just see yourself.
He can feel that I do tricks now when I'm on stage to keep me at that level or
when I start to imagine my brain going someplace else to stay present.
You know what?
It only works.
The only reason why that ever happens with me,
if I lose a commitment to something,
it's because what I'm talking about is really not that good.
It's really that simple with me.
It's not ready yet.
I haven't,
I haven't toned it up enough.
I'm not excited about doing every bit that I,
that I do that I love.
Like I've never gotten to certain bits and been like,
like when I get to,
you know,
any,
any my gay marriage bit that bit when I get to that bit,
I never go,
God I gotta do this cause I know this bit's gonna crush.
I know it's going to be fun.
But when I get to a bit that's like Kinda like not really there,
you know,
I'm still fucking with it.
I'm still working on it and I'm like,
ah,
I don't even want to do this right now cause this is a,
this doesn't feel ready.
But you know,
you're,
you're committed to talking about it.
It's very difficult to change gears.
I've seen you like feel uncomfortable with debt because of some situation.
I can't remember if it was like you've sensed the audience didn't like the gay
humor or the,
uh,
I forget which were what club we were at.
But I remember like you even brought it up like halfway through it and you're
like,
oh,
you know,
I have a lot of Dick Jokes.
Or he said something like that.
Or I have a lot of gay jokes or I can't remember what it was like maybe six
months ago you did it.
Maybe it was a damn.
When you bring these things up right now are so unspecific.
All those kids,
I don't remember any audience getting upset at gay jokes.
They were getting upset.
You just kind of sensed it.
Like how,
you know,
I'd say that sometimes cause I sense it because I know I talked to Jim Norton
about this.
I go,
dude,
I thought that I had a problem because they had so many Dick Jokes in my act
until I went to see Norton and laugh my ass off as dude has like fucking,
it's one long Dick joke,
but it's hilarious.
I mean,
I loved it.
I said,
now I don't feel bad cause all I never think about that.
I never worry about that cause he's crazy.
Right,
right,
right.
But I thought about that.
I'm like,
you know,
I've said it on stage before.
I have like a jokes of dude's sucking dude's Dicks,
don't want to and it's all different premises and all different shit.
And every now and then I'll like bring it up on stage.
Like man,
I've got a lot of jokes about dudes getting their dick sucked.
But it wasn't because I felt something in the audience.
It was because of me being aware.
Right.
Just trying to like,
especially now like trying to put together like the,
the material for a special,
uh,
by the way,
we still don't know where they're going,
what the fuck we're going to do in Vancouver.
But more than half the tickets are sold out.
So the vogue theater,
which is a beautiful theater isn't,
yeah.
Did you do it?
I've done it.
What's it like?
Super Nice.
One of those old school theaters that have been around,
you know like back in the day of Alice and Columbus,
Ohio or yeah,
just really cool.
Yeah.
Some of those stages are amazing though.
Staters you do around the country,
you just walk,
you know what does,
what does this plug,
going back to this what?
What?
What does this plug in that you made cause explain that because I think it's a
too,
man.
You can't change gears like that.
Do I know what the fuck?
Oh the plugin for the website.
Just talking about the vogue theaters then you can't just change gears like
that.
I'm looking at it up the,
the actual dates on the counter.
Brian.
Brian,
Brian got to stay in the grooves on.
Don't be like talking about completely different.
Talking about comedy and Y'all going back and forth.
When did you do the vote?
Um,
years ago when I could actually do theater.
Years ago when you could do it.
You can do with heaters anymore.
Wait,
four years ago,
I think I did it.
You can't do theaters anymore.
I have a pen to by myself recently.
No.
June 10th is when I'm at the vogue.
What happened?
What changed?
Not being on television,
just as silly.
Just so the last comic standing and then there was like a,
you rode the same level for a while.
For a long time.
I think even still now I think out of the same level.
Well not theater's name.
I still do really well clubs.
Was the theater's things you did with the last comic standing group or do we
just me,
well we did it together.
We did theaters together when,
when I met John,
John and I did the maxim comedy tour and we did shit did to me and you and
Charlie Murphy?
Yeah.
Did,
uh,
what did the 22 dates?
Went to?
Gigs.
Got Whole.
It was a whole month of October or whenever it happened.
All theaters and uh,
except a couple of comedy clubs,
a few comedy clubs too.
But that was fun as shit.
And with theaters when,
if you're a comic that are in theaters,
man,
some of it now that I've learned really falls in the hands of the people
promoting it more.
I mean you as your online presence and and I mean even now,
look how fast Internet was.
I have more of an online presence.
It's up.
Then when we did that tour because Twitter wasn't really,
we weren't,
Twitter wasn't around and in,
in Twitter.
Yeah.
Now it's getting easier.
But those promoters really dictate.
So then,
well we didn't have promoters at all.
Zero.
We had zero for that.
They decided this is what happened.
They sold a fucking thing to bud light.
It was the bud light maxim comedy toward these guys sold this tour.
They packaged it with me.
And the reason why Charlie was on was because me and Charlie have the same
agent.
My agent convinced me that Charlie was doing really well and clubs and you know,
help because he was just coming off the,
you know,
the Chappelle show.
And so these guys basically sold it and then did nothing to promote the shows.
They were getting a guaranteed amount of income and they just did a crap job.
We didn't do any radio.
We did not any and build up,
say there's two big liking,
not 1000 feet.
How many was the biggest one?
We plan like a 10,000 are the ones that we did well and whereas once I always
did well in like Houston who sold out Houston.
But I always do well in Houston and we,
you know,
we did well in,
uh,
in Phoenix and I always do well,
and we would go into market to where you would sell out and I would sell out.
I didn't,
I didn't know nothing about Charlie at the time,
so I don't know how he did.
And those theaters were so big.
You're like,
I would pull more people if I was at the club.
You know what I mean?
Like I just,
that just showed you how nobody knew that you weren't,
you know what I mean?
That that tour was in Tom.
Well,
the fact that,
you know,
now we have the podcast,
there's that completely changes.
Any kind of promotion.
I've never been able to move tickets as easily and sell tickets to sell radios
dead in every city.
You Go.
Cheddar's no,
he's not dead.
It's dying.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
and you know,
they're all fucking scared.
These,
these,
these morning Djs,
you know,
there's only a few of them that have balls in,
a lot of them are fucking terrified cause they know they're during the chopping
block.
You know,
for every Bob and Tom that can just relax.
this guy's had been around forever.
They're not going anywhere and they do whatever they want.
You know,
for every one of them there's some poor guy who is trying to survive and fucking
Cleveland and doesn't have their stations going to turn into all iPod channel or
stuff like that.
Oh yeah man.
I mean,
I mean how many people were I look at even Tom like is,
is fucked.
He's,
he's out in the cold.
All of those guys,
like even guys who did really well on radio or fucked,
it's like they,
you bought all this pain.
No place for a homing.
Yeah.
Listen to this.
When they work out,
when he,
well we want to get you doing one of these,
man.
I think you would,
you would be awesome doing a podcast and you're always looking for shit to do
after your shows.
I think the neat,
my vending machine food.
Yeah.
When you're talking about,
you're on some crazy diet right now because you eat too much.
A hotel vending machine.
It's like I'm a 500 pound buried alive type eater.
I consume that much junk food.
After a show railing,
I go to the bank machine.
I'll get three or four rows,
donuts,
maybe some cheese.
It's if they have the bacon,
a chip things,
and then I'll get some tea and I'll set it right next to my computer and then I
start just seeing where my youtube brain takes me.
Just eating,
bouncing youtube,
watching stuff,
and we'll go on youtube,
let's make you productive milk,
right?
Let's have a John Heffron podcast.
You could do it with opening acts.
Do you have opening acts or cool.
Or when you were signing them,
you were saying there was the one guy when you
had to pee on stage.
That was douchey.
Yeah,
I mean I think you know,
every weekend some guys are cool,
some guys are,
you know,
you don't bring guys with you.
You must do the low.
I don't,
yeah.
Everyone who I used to bring with me ended up getting a special and then they
don't want to you know,
feature anymore.
They kind of get that.
Well that's good but there's,
there's other young guys coming up,
man,
it's really funny Guy Damien and then ones that are that are really bad that
don't want to take any advice and then you reach that stage.
We go,
do I want to be a guy who gives advice or I want to be just sit there like what
was my place to advice?
You give advice but you also tell them like how to do it when they open for you.
You tell them like what good don't do that bit and the one thing that bothers
you don't tell them what you told us.
You told them not to,
what not to do certain bits.
The bits that that I will say is the,
let me ask a question before have you joke guy?
That's really the only time I open my mouth now.
But you'd tell them they can't do that.
Well what?
Well you give me.
Give us an example for the non comedy oriented folks.
All right,
so how many people here at Facebook?
So I was on Facebook,
Greece,
and they tell him to stop doing.
How many,
how many people have cats?
Well,
my cat recently and then I always go,
listen,
if you're going to do the same exact joke,
we guard lists of what the what your pole than stone has the question.
Just go Facebook.
Why do you care?
What if that's their style?
Some people like to set things up like that,
you know?
Well then I get on stage.
I'm like,
so I was in my,
you know,
I had a big wheel as a kid.
Yeah,
I know,
I know.
You've heard a big wheels.
I'm not asking you because you're asking permission to do the joke when you ask
questions.
So what you're saying is that this guy is fucked up,
this audience for you?
Yes.
That's ridiculous.
I know.
It's silly.
You might have retards for audience members.
You got to develop your own podcast son.
So you have your fans that come to see you and then you'd have to worry about
shaping your audience.
You worried that this guy is poorly trained,
your audience like a dog that pisses all over the carpet and when you get off
stage the dog doesn't listen,
like stop pissing all over the place.
That's what the,
I guess if you put it that way it feels like,
you know,
well Daddy,
can I stay the night at someone's house?
I don't know.
What kind of food do they have cable?
I guess I'm being a little too protective of [inaudible] everything.
Yes,
I'm being honest with you.
That's absolutely ridiculous and I love you,
but you've got to stop doing that.
This is the only thing you should ever tell comics not to do it.
Don't steal material and don't step on my premises because some dudes will step
on premises that on purpose to try to fuck you up.
Like how you might do some crazy bid about getting stranded,
you know,
in the tiger cage at the circus and,
and all of a sudden this mother fucker will have some crazy circus story.
Anybody here like tigers?
Dude,
I would ever marry.
How many times have you worked with guys and you do Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
and you do a set with them Thursday and then Friday they'll open for you and do
the same fucking subjects that you do on purpose.
You can tell that they're not even formed bits.
Yeah,
they're just trying to snip on your premise is so common amongst young haters,
you know,
and it's usually guys that are creative in the first place.
This is why they're trying to fuck you up.
I've done that with like,
I do some material out just getting a little bit older,
but I'm also in my forties where you see the young guy 22 so I'm getting older.
What Dude?
You're 22 rarely three.
You're going to complain about getting older?
Yeah.
All right,
I'm going to stop.
So every comic,
I've worked with them now I won't,
I won't let him steal.
Don't let him step on your shit.
You know you don't want guys who suck if you,
you know it was sucks.
Don't use them again but let him do his own thing,
man.
Shit,
what do you worry about in the stupid questions?
All you need a Goddamn podcast.
John Heffron can I can,
I should.
I could have these guys on and maybe give them advice on the podcast and la so
they would be like you,
you're different intel,
their them.
Maybe their best jokes will come out of,
hey,
who's got an Xbox Xbox and makes you suck your mother's pussy.
Maybe that's going to be as big closer is quite would be hilarious style.
Maybe that's his style.
It's just asking stupid fucking questions and getting up.
But it a clap like ironically
I got alive.
Did good.
I got a lot of prospects.
You were asking questions.
Is that okay?
Oh you you so they will say to you,
you gotta love that.
Got a lot of applause.
That's like,
well you have like keg stations like that where you guys are defending their Aco
and I got a lot of flaws breaks I've had.
Yeah.
So you've criticized them and then they'd come back with,
I got a lot of applause because the crop,
any charts or pie graphs,
you could show the guy how good
you're telling them that what they did was not good and they're saying,
well people clapped.
Yeah,
that's accepted and said that I just,
yeah,
I'm not a fan.
So it's because you're just apparently am violence to mad at buyer the most I've
stood up the whole time.
Yeah.
Just don't ask questions.
But here's what I think.
You are obviously a perfectionist when it comes to your act.
Your act is very tight and very home and everything and I think you see sloppy
shit and people's act and it hurts you.
Like you're seeing it in yourself,
you know,
and that your audience has to be subjected to it.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Well I was watching this and that's what they say,
right?
When you're insecure.
W when you,
when you criticize someone,
you shit on someone,
well you're really are afraid of that and yourself,
right?
Yeah.
But on the question once,
cause I don't ask,
I don't know why it bugs me can be honest because that's why bugs,
that's why thieves bug me.
The reason why thieves always bugged me is cause I was always terrified of being
completely on original.
Like the idea of like what if I just repeat it all.
Only things and other people said and tried to claim them as my own like sounds
so gross.
Anything like,
you know,
I would watch like people get arrested on like cop shows and Shit like that and
uh,
you know,
like any,
any,
any sort of show where,
you know,
they recreate this guy went on a rampage right now.
Fuck.
What if I do that?
I would always think that like,
I don't wanna,
I don't want to be a guy who wants a ride.
Robin banks.
Why?
Because I have friends who've robbed banks.
You know,
I know a couple of dudes who rob banks who robbed a bank and wanting to thought
about robbing a bank.
You know,
I mean,
shit happens.
So I,
I'm,
I,
when I see like laziness or fucked up shit and other people,
that's what it makes me mad.
And what makes me mad is that I'm afraid of seeing in myself.
So are you afraid of seeing him and yourself?
Is that why you're telling all these guys to stop?
I honestly from for,
from
a place of where I think I can give them a little bit of a help to make it
almost like a golf swing.
This is a bad exam or like throwing a punch.
I,
every week I go someplace,
I'll find a,
like a boxing coach or whatever and I work,
every guy wants to show me how to throw a punch different.
Right?
But here's the difference.
You Ready?
You're seeking help.
Okay.
You're going to someone and you're saying,
I want to improve this.
Will you help me what they're doing?
It's just living their life and doing their act and in performing their art,
the way they see fit and what you're doing is offering unsolicited advice.
So if they came up to you,
that would be a different thing.
If they came up to you and go,
look,
John,
you're an awesome comedian.
If you could give me some advice or anything you can do,
which I've done for friends,
you know,
and I've,
I've done some unsolicited shit for friends to where I pulled them aside and go,
dude,
you got to stop doing that.
But like,
this bit's fucked up.
Like to,
I'm 100% over,
over controlling and stuff like that.
Like I'll even say now,
okay,
I guess I'm a tool a way,
like an MCO.
Get on stage and and go,
hey,
are you guys in a good mood tonight?
Clap,
clap,
clap.
Come on.
And you can do better than that.
I don't like that,
man.
That makes me more where I always go,
listen,
don't give an option.
Just tell them how they're doing.
Get onstage and say,
you guys look like you're in a great mood.
Why?
Ask them why.
Ask them like,
I don't know why.
So I will say,
but you're right though.
I was at the gym recently and I was doing a kettle bell swing and one of the
trainers at the gym came over and said,
you're doing it wrong.
Here's how to do it.
And I was so offended.
I'm like,
no,
I'm not.
I have friends that do kettlebells.
This is exactly how you're supposed to,
and I felt this probably the same way that,
well,
that sounds like he was incorrect though,
was you are you are,
you're pretty much of a spot.
I didn't ask,
I didn't ask for his help.
Right.
So I,
regardless if he was like,
I probably what he said was,
could have helped me and I didn't like when people give me advice when they're
not right.
I didn't know this guy was.
Yeah,
I thought they were completely wrong.
I,
you know,
that's a,
a martial arts thing.
Two guys will come over and give you advice all the time,
like [inaudible] aren't even as good at you will like give you advice.
And they're just,
it's like some weird fucking Alpha control thing,
like telling you how to do it.
I'm like,
that's not right.
I'm saying I'm,
I'm all down for advice.
If you know what the fuck you're doing.
But it's hard for people to take advice from a people they don't like,
that's tough.
Or you know,
if your,
they're jealous of you,
they got some weird thing with you.
Like you're the headliner,
you're John Half Ron's last comic standing and they're,
you know,
Bobby and mcfuck stick from Columbus,
Ohio,
you know?
Yeah.
And you know that guy.
It's weird.
Even though the punch thing,
how often every week,
how it's such a different,
every guy says I punch wrong and it's in,
well,
everybody's got their own style and then,
you know,
but it's all that Joe Frazier,
you said throw a leftist.
Even Mike Tyson did you know Joe Frazier and Mike Tyson through two totally
different left talks.
Joel Fraser's too,
that,
that palm down left hook.
And Mike Tyson would throw the,
the palm facing him left hook and both are awesome.
You know,
there's a bus route,
another bang.
We had a,
yeah,
we had a boss on the podcast.
It was awesome.
I love it.
One of the greatest guys ever.
And uh,
you know,
I mean no one can tell you what to do if you're doing it effectively in pool.
The game of pool does a legendary player named Keith McCready.
He was in the color of money.
Remember that movie?
The color of money with Tom Cruise.
You play the Pool Hustler and play that guy.
That one is that um,
pool hall when I lived in Chicago.
Oh really?
Yeah,
he played,
he played this guy,
uh,
Keith McCready play this Guy Grady Stephens and Keith McCready was known as like
one of the greatest gambler a pool players in the history of California and
nationwide.
He used to walk around with a TV show with a tee shirt,
rather walk around to professional tournaments with a tee shirt on.
That said,
the world gets the eight.
And what that means is he will spot the world,
the eight ball,
they're playing nine ball and he will give them an extra money ball.
The whole,
like he would gamble with anybody but he,
you know,
be cranked out.
It was fucking mind on who knows why he couldn't miss.
And he had a terrible,
like his,
his fundamentals were completely wrong.
He would put his arm out completely sideways because he learned how to play as a
little kid when he was so small,
he couldn't even reach the table.
So you'd have this side arm strokes.
He would do it totally,
completely wrong,
but he would rob everybody.
Right,
right.
Like who's to tell him that he's wrong?
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
yeah,
going on stage and asking,
so who's here having a good time?
You guys,
uh,
you guys look like you have,
are you having a good time tonight?
You know?
Yeah,
you would get upset,
but what if he came back with the greatest line ever right after that?
You know what I'm saying?
I mean it's just,
yeah,
I mean it's just a style man.
It's a style.
I D I will just dive of new leaves that go,
which I will sit in the back,
eat my chicken tenders and just walk out to it.
My only pet peeves I have ever when guys are opening up his guys that um,
the,
it could be guys that use the word fuck too much.
Like they're,
they use it so much.
It's uncomfortable to use it after them cause they'll be like,
some guys look good,
they'll get nervous.
No,
I fucking,
this fucking guy was fucking told you to fucking this fucking just fucking you
man.
And then fucking becomes,
ah,
you know,
it becomes,
yeah,
it comes this guy,
uh,
that sounds stupid,
but fucking,
you know,
when you,
there's,
you utilize the war.
If you utilize the word properly,
it's a great word.
You know,
this fucking guy thinks that he can do it.
You know?
That's funny.
They know what I'm saying.
It's like relays fucking has,
it brings more meaning to more volume to the sentence.
But when you use it all the time,
it does nothing hilarious.
Hilarious.
It just Jackson and throws.
Especially if you just say hilarious.
Tell everybody why you say
Maddie cursors.
We have a friend named Matt Kirsh who I used to open up for Joe [inaudible]
going to date.
Oh,
he was hilarious back in the day.
I haven't seen him recently,
but uh,
he uh,
he somehow out of nowhere it started saying the word hilarious and like every
sentence.
So He'd be like,
oh,
hilarious.
I went out to get Starbucks today.
How did it areas,
it was the most delicious Starbucks ever headed areas.
It was like
he had a hilarious stroke and it won't go Larry A and now I hung
out with him the other day,
how I am on a couple of podcasts and I don't remember it now,
so I don't know if maybe hilarious it up.
I think he said Hilarious,
but I don't think it was as much.
There's no way he keeps that up.
You set up a furious pace then the no way weird.
Just face like I remember when I was in high school after everything we said
we'd go brown like for no reason.
So like,
and I couldn't,
my dad literally was going to kill me one day,
you know,
like he's like,
Hey,
do you mow a lawn?
I'm going to do it after I,
you watched the new thriller video.
He's like,
you do that one more in our group in our group.
But it's the word powerful,
powerful,
powerful.
In our group we say and it all comes from my crazy friend Larry who's nodding in
the group anymore.
We kicked him out of the band.
It's one in a different direction.
Much love Larry,
wherever you are.
But he also came up with the head slap.
If you see like sometimes me and Goldberg when we're doing the UFC,
if we get excited we go,
oh my goodness,
I'll slap him on the forehead too.
That I pray for.
My friend Larry and the,
the word powerful came from Larry.
You know what?
I'm glad it's over.
We did for like,
it was like I got so sick of it every time.
It's like very nice.
Well,
you know what,
not much respect for the greatest movie of all time.
I have to say one great,
great comedy movie Barat Wins.
If I one one great comedy movie,
man,
it's tough to fuck with that movie.
When those guys were both naked wrestling in the hotel room,
I'm sorry,
that's one of the funniest scenes in the history of the world.
You know,
they always said that.
That's a way you could tell if your partners is cheating on your hanging out
with a different group of people as they start doing a weird,
so if you're with a girl or something,
then I'll for no reason,
she just goes powerful.
You're like,
wait a minute,
that's new.
That's not in our group.
Never Thought Eddie Bravo,
you turn to pitch.
People are going to start doing that.
But what powerful is is you know,
the way we say powerful.
So just to explain looks,
I want to go uh,
what time,
what time you got this?
You want to get some food?
How about five o'clock all right,
powerful.
Let's do it
more powerful cause nobody ever sampled tickets.
Then you say like you'll say powerful things to powerful new laptop.
Ooh,
you know,
powerful new sneakers,
but it's some people want to be,
so when you say that,
he'd go,
hey,
where do you want eat?
Arby's.
Powerful.
You.
Okay,
well my parents said,
you're ridiculous.
You got issues.
It all comes back to you.
Yeah,
he's got a goddamn theme he needs.
He needs a friend and you knew that honey pot.
I'm telling you,
you are fucking up your brain going on the road by yourself.
You're doing this too much.
You're overthinking too much to ever.
You're spending too much time alone.
That's why you're eating donuts and all depressed.
When we go on the road,
we go on the road with a group of us is Joey and Brian and Ari and we go,
it's a rolling party.
So it's not that what I miss,
I miss my kids,
I miss my wife,
I miss my house,
I miss my bed,
I miss my car,
I miss all that stuff.
But when I'm on the road,
but I'm not lonely.
I have my buddies,
we have great times.
When you're doing is you're doing a show so you have fun during the show and
then the rest of your day sucks a bag of dicks.
And why does it suck about your decks?
Cause you're too cheap to
pay an opening it,
right.
That's what it is.
You're fucking,
you're sitting in your hotel room watching entourage.
You should be going to the moon will,
no,
I'm what sitting hotel watching what you guys are doing,
right?
You guys were in Portland,
This is,
you guys were important in,
in prime was doing a thing from the Portland Club.
You had your iPad,
you are streaming a Diaz was Zara.
And then he wanted to decide to smoke and whatever.
And I,
and I fall asleep.
I was eating donuts.
Watch that,
fell asleep,
woke up the next day.
And I was like,
oh that was crazy.
When a Diaz was outspoken and then I later went,
that didn't fucking happen.
I wasn't with that.
That was those guys in Portland,
like what my life site and then you just see carnage,
caramel corn,
me sleep.
And I'm like,
I gotta go do something.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
You're in a sugar coma.
Yeah.
Just thinking that you guys are so silly to just know when you guys do your
stuff and you're tweeting,
it's,
you should be doing the same thing,
man,
when like we did when we did the Maxim tour,
when did the maximum cor,
you and me and Tate and we had a great,
we had a great fucking time and Charlie,
Charlie's a cool motherfucker.
I've got to get him on the podcast too.
You know,
we should do,
we should do a God damn reunion with the three of us and get rid rich Charlie's
cousin that was with them or what's the guy's name?
Rich.
Super Nice Guy.
When I ran into them on Maui,
I went to the four seasons in Maui on vacation with the Rogan clan and just out
of nowhere I see rich at the,
at the,
uh,
at the clerk desk or whatever the fuck would you check in?
I go,
what's up dude?
And he goes,
oh,
should we do,
I go,
we're on vacation was oh shit.
Trolleys here with Eddie.
I got to hang out with any Murphy.
Really Dude,
Eddie Murphy,
I cannot to Eddie Murphy goes,
man,
you're a funny motherfucker.
I don't want it.
How would you not send that?
Even it didn't even seem real.
I'm like,
this is not happening.
There's no way I'm meeting Eddie Murphy and he's telling me that I'm a funny
motherfucker.
I was like,
wow,
I go,
thank you very much man,
that that means the world coming from you.
And then Charlie gives me a hug and then I'm hanging out with,
you know,
his mom's there and his family's there and shit like that.
And he's got eight kids and they all look like Eddie but fat.
A lot of them looked like Eddie dude.
Like in a weird way like Eddie Different Eddie,
but weird.
No,
it wasn't like the movies.
Eddie Murphy's cool as fuck man.
You know,
I thought it would be weird because he's such a huge movie star,
but he's just sitting there eating.
He's like,
this is like a outdoor lunch spot and he's just sitting down eating,
eating.
That would be so great to have lunch with Eddie Murphy was so weird to have
Charlie and here the thing that press me about Charlie,
Charlie Murphy used to get these air,
not air force one,
just the all white,
um,
Nike's and he'd get a little bit of blue on the top of your shoe.
Laces would go from your genes,
right?
And it would leave them in the green room and I would go,
hey,
you left your shoes here.
Oh No,
they get that blue stuff on them.
Yeah,
but you're not going to,
no,
I already got a new Bucer are white and you don't understand the black community
and how,
how important it is to be flossing.
That's not nearly as ridiculous as that chains it.
He would wear rich come out and went right to hold out your hands and he's just
taking his rings off his finger,
putting on Rich's fingers.
And he took,
he took neck,
he had these big crazy medallions.
They're covered in diamonds.
Okay.
I mean there,
there are those rapper things that you see like job rule wearing,
Joe Rose even alive anymore.
One of those guys,
little Wayne,
you know,
he's got all these crazy diamonds and,
and Charlie would would go to rich and he would leave one on just to keep it
classy,
keep it classy Charlie.
But he would take most of his heavy shit off.
I was hoping I'd run into Charlie.
I got the guy from skin industries owl.
He sent me a watch for some work I did with him and he sent me,
I always wanted a Cardiay roadster.
So he sent me his Cardiay roadster,
not one piece on it,
didn't have diamonds on,
he's 30 so just imagine,
watch completely blinged out.
Right.
And he goes,
you did some work,
but the budget's gimme a couple of bucks for it,
you know,
stupid washers on you.
So I had it on this diamond thing.
It was so blinged out that you couldn't,
as a white guy,
he couldn't wear know.
I'm thinking about getting me one of them right now.
Just listening to you.
You couldn't wear it.
Hey could you just got to have some personality,
man,
not me.
So I took it,
the foam pawnshops aunt acardiac and the cardiac guy goes,
if we did those diamonds,
it'd be worth about 250,000 we don't know where those diamonds came from,
so you know,
and it's stolen.
Nobody believed.
I had all the paperwork and stuff.
So then I was like,
how do I run into Charlie Murphy Cause I'm going to have it and then they run
into him and then I bet you I could sell.
So Cardiay we told you that it was stolen.
No,
they're just am aftermarket diamonds.
The diamonds definitely were aftermarket.
Yeah.
But it was Al and Al gave me the richness of cognitive.
Definitely didn't do the diamonds did not.
Okay.
Definitely.
Definitely does.
So how much is it worth by?
Give it back to him.
It was,
he said give it back to them.
Yeah,
that was a whole thing.
I couldn't,
I didn't know what to do with the walks,
the whole thing.
I was the whole thing when I read great way of leg saying,
oh you know,
so don't,
one time I worked when I hosted the don't even have to explore.
Sure.
The MMA awards.
When I was in a toward it,
I was like,
I'm gonna wear it.
I'm wearing a Tuxedo.
And then I went to blame me.
I can't pull it off,
took it off,
and then I sent it back to it because I'm like,
I don't know what I can do with this thing.
I've had nothing.
I don't know if he wears crazy shit like that,
but he's,
yeah,
and you know he also tries Ferraris.
I know he's a porn star.
He was a porn starting at a porn company and then he got into skin industry
isn't meant.
Yeah.
So I gave it back to them.
I found out my watch just yesterday was on,
I think it was TMZ or something like that.
I found out my watch is what the government looks for because of terrorism.
If you will wear this watch,
you're automatically automatically get flagged.
What like the fuck are you talking about?
It's a certain brand of Casio.
Watch that square.
Yeah.
It's the old school Casio Watch.
Very Romano has one that's the only watch you ever wear.
Same here.
I love,
that's my watch.
I've had since I was a kid,
so I always buy it now.
I'll buy it in different colors.
Where are you hearing the government's flagging people for tall while fine.
I'll find the dumbest shit I've ever heard.
No,
because what it has is training camps,
terrorist training camps,
they all this certain kind
of watch did it too for for whatever reason.
Cause they could program it to like set off bombs and stuff like that.
Yeah.
So it ended the exact wow Gus you wearing this Casio watch might be terrorist.
That is ridiculous.
F 91 w yeah.
It's don't watch.
This is so fucking stupid.
I swore,
I thought you were trolling.
No,
I wasn't showing this was going to be a joke and you're going to have a joke at
the end and you're going to no,
no,
no.
I can't believe that's true.
I guess the reason I got it,
cause Kmart has it for $12.
So every time I lose it or scratch it,
I was going to Kmart and buy a new one for 12 bucks and now they started making
them in different colors.
Like they,
they made them in different colors back in the day too.
But this one is like the,
it's like now I'm flagged if you go to the airport wearing this watch,
there are trained to look for this watch.
So stupid.
And you know,
that's the one ray Romano has that watch
get a new one.
I know.
Yeah.
Little bit of a terrorist yourself.
A bit of a mark says.
Anyway,
guys,
he's an awesome guy.
You know,
he said something really funny.
We did that.
A taping back to back of that.
Paul prevents a show,
the green room.
And uh,
when he was up there he was talking about how,
you know,
he goes to Vegas,
he does,
he shows they're doing it.
Like I think he doesn't meant the wind might be the Mirage.
I Dunno.
But he does it some big ass giant place.
Right.
And he said,
then right before I go out there,
I feel like a fraud.
It's like they're all cheering because I don't even feel like that's really me.
Like I've tricked them.
It goes out there and kills for an hour and then just feels like shit and
leaves.
It's weird.
It's like the really nice guys,
like for whatever reason,
like those nice guys,
like Ray Romano was super,
Super Nice Guy,
but those really nice guys.
It's like they never get to enjoy their success.
You know,
Kevin James is the same way.
Well he enjoys it a little.
She watched a lot of,
uh,
that's my biggest la stories as I've watched a lot of UFC fights at his house.
It's cool,
although he's got a rule like where I don't talk like during the fight,
you know,
cause I know when that rule,
but I don't,
I don't know him well enough that,
you know,
some people are like quiet.
Like I,
when I watched UFC,
I run it and I don't have anybody over and I sit there pay,
it's always about me and beat.
I say,
give me a town Saturday.
If we're doing a
hold on a second.
Wait,
would it seem what you're saying?
So I'm afraid to like talk,
you know what I mean?
Cause you're at his house and it's just,
we're kind of respect.
I don't want to stock Babin and he'd be the guy who's like,
can you not talk?
I like to listen to row.
So it's not a rule that he has is just,
you don't feel comfortable at his house.
But yes,
overthinking thing you over-thought that's the point where you made it a rule at
his house.
I say you introduced it like Kevin's this fucking speak before me.
You know he's got a fucking Turkey leg in a fucking full of meat with the mouth,
but he gone,
he me
bring another and made it a rule in your head before you introduced it.
No,
I guess,
I don't know.
It's so crazy and maybe that's why it happened to him at all,
but he's like,
I might have for,
and he just sits there like a log.
He doesn't say anything.
He's fucking funny.
Everyone else's cracking jokes.
You want me to talk?
Does it even say anything?
Watching fights with your friends is actually at home on a TV.
Might be a little better than watching it live if you have all your backups.
Well,
you know what?
Here's the thing.
My opinion is shit because I'm,
they're not even watching it live with my friends.
I'm watching it live and working.
So even though I enjoy the fight very much,
it's not the same experience as watching it live when you don't have to talk.
Cause when you don't have to talk,
you can shoot the shift with your friends.
You guys were doing acid
brown.
He's a shit.
Everybody's drunk as fuck.
It's a totally different experience.
It's a party watching the fights and when you're watching the fight,
the lie with your friends,
like I used to love going with Eddie.
We used to go and watch the WEC ones at the hard rock and the evening and we
used to go fucking,
it was awesome,
man.
We got,
I didn't have to work.
We sit in there drinking and having a good time,
but there's something about watching him on TV.
Man,
we don't have to deal with all those shit heads.
You know,
like this weekend is going to be 55,000 fucking people in Toronto.
Oh my God.
And it's probably actually going to be way better than 55,000 people in America
because the number of Douche bags per capita is way smaller in Canada.
It just is.
It's just,
you know,
people certainly fuck you over there.
So fucking move their queer.
I'm just telling you,
you might not be a Douche bag,
but you can't deny that.
But the huge numbers of Douche bags we have in this country,
it's not saying America is an awesome,
it's not saying that I don't love living,
but individually,
but you click too many people together to become one big douchebag Auto Bot,
you know,
or yeah,
yeah.
Wherever it just clicks in and then suddenly you hit that common dinner.
You ever think about living somewhere else other than la?
All the time.
My parents just bought a in in Detroit where I'm from,
30 acres pine tree,
50 Bucks,
110,000 it denied 90 stall.
Indoor riding likes almost like a hockey arena.
Indoor heated that you can ride your horses 90 stalls.
Nice house pine trees for like $110,000.
My storage unit that I pay for in Los Angeles costs more.
Yeah.
You know,
when you start thinking that I have been,
that's got like a,
the more,
cause my dad has a shooting range out there.
He put in like sh I love guns and we go out there and dogs run around and you
shoot stuff.
And what I'm thinking is just,
you don't,
you're never even home anyway.
I've been on the road since November every and nobody I know hustles more than
half Ron.
That's what I came up with.
A,
you know,
you're out there every day.
Yeah.
So now your web browser,
it just stinks cause you've been overthinking your browser history.
And I offer,
so I've had a joke in my act for ever and it just kind of out of context when I
say w,
uh,
when your wife sees that you have zero Internet history,
she knows something's up.
Well that's your wife checking
your phone.
No,
it's not.
It's not a,
it's a fake bit.
It's not a legitimate,
you know,
tell that Bitch,
oh,
I've done that before.
We go.
And then I go,
they should have a,
a browser that has fake sites.
So because sometimes in the,
in the,
due to the Joel Gray,
it's Bluetooth or you go and save the world.
Dot Org automatically pops up,
right?
So I was sitting in a hotel room by myself once,
eating donuts and stuff and went,
there's gotta be a way to actually make this as a browser.
And A,
and by the way,
I was talking to somebody about it and they were saying some Chi was at a
convention.
He know when he's got his computer hooked up to where 600 people could see.
And he starts typing like whatever the his program is,
you know,
to show people.
And uh,
all the history of like uga.com let me know all popped up for all these people
to see.
So anyway,
so I created this web browser called history rewrite where you can be on any
website and you all Wyatt and one of our preloaded sites automatically pops up.
So I created this a browse,
a friend of mine,
like a guy who does it.
So you have the idea.
So you went to history rewrite.com you'll see it.
Yeah.
So I went to him and I go,
is this hard to do?
Is this?
He goes,
oh,
that should know that's a a white list.
And he started explaining,
he goes,
I think I can do this.
So we did it.
So and then so what it does is it blows out your history and the throws 20 sites
in there.
Right.
So it's never completely empty.
And did you choose the site?
Yeah,
yeah.
We picked the sites just to see if it worked.
But now like we can change them up and stop forgetting to make them funny.
He never put this funny thing happened to me in it.
No,
you don't put that down with your porn stars and shit.
Your selfish ass defeating the whole purpose.
It's not bad.
You know he said to me once during,
shut down my account,
mount assholes and I was like,
why does shut down your account?
There's nothing or you need to do anything.
Just some,
some girl pulled her pants down like that's it.
Yeah,
you can even see her.
But he didn't tell me that.
Some guy had his face up this chick's ass while this was going.
She pulled her pants down,
he stuffed his face in her ass.
I'm like,
oh,
he ate her ass on camera.
Oh,
wonder why he wouldn't,
you know,
wonder why they wouldn't want to have that displayed throughout offices with the
big Ustream labeled the bottom of it.
She had a thong on and he was just kissing.
Dude,
it doesn't matter.
You can't be eating someone's ass in an office.
You walk in,
if you're walking and you know,
we're watching this podcast and you know you're working and you're supposed to
be doing something.
You've got this in a small window in the corner.
You know what I mean?
But you're doing all your paperwork and everything and I just listen.
He's guys,
no big deal.
That's fine.
Until you walk in,
you see some girl's ass and some guys get his face burden.
Yeah.
And then you watch Andy Dick and he has his dick hanging out,
slapping some guy in the face with it and you're like,
okay,
how is he like listed as top hit on Ustream?
What are you talking about?
Have you seen any of Andy Dixie stream videos?
Pulls his dick out and the couple I saw he was,
it was a slapping some dude in the face with his dick.
No.
Did she have no,
no.
Swear to God.
I saw with my own eyes.
But let's say you're at Twitter.
Twitter,
please,
please verify.
I did not
have time to Google this.
Certain things I just,
I don't have too much dignity to Google.
So we came up with that with the browser.
The guy did it.
We,
we throw it out there just to see and tested it and stuff and we had like a lot
of people download it and the first I don't,
I don't promote it looks pretty cool.
Yeah,
it's like a cool idea.
It only does two things.
Like I've had some people go,
you should have it two more.
No,
it's only there for,
we make it as simple as possible.
We have,
you know,
we're upgrading it where you can put insights you want to be able to get,
but that,
you know,
they just took a little bit of a learning charge on this thing about free.
If look at you,
you're just trying to help manage this and it gives me something to talk about
when I'm on radio.
But it also,
yeah,
that's a good idea.
It serves a purpose and it's a thing and you helping push you with men.
They post it up on people.
I always get people go,
well,
no,
because let's say,
but let's say you're going to the hooker.
No,
let's see.
Ah,
you know,
surprise party for my wife and your wife was a come home and see you.
You're looking them.
I tried to mask it and my wife comes home and she sees it,
goes through my browser and says,
I can't believe you were trying to,
trying to make a surprise party for him.
I'd be like,
Bitch,
why you looking at my fucking computer?
But now she'll go,
oh,
I saw you bought John Hough.
You went to John Hepburn website.
Does he like,
yeah,
so which,
which I was gonna put you guys in there.
I don't think I did this one.
Yeah.
Do you ever come home and your wife is looking through your fucking computer?
I got my own computer.
Does she ever look through your computer?
I would have never sees his wife.
Yeah,
I would.
I would imagine she she,
she probably,
you know thing.
It's on the old dude's so fucking confident.
How do I know Brian is Brian?
Set up cameras at your have bags.
I'll show you the tapes.
Cameras.
It's just an easy install.
You can wait to say why of my wife's by going hilarious.
Today's been bananas.
So dog,
particularly
funny
ever.
You've never caught your wife fucking around with your computer.
It's not like the number one way people get caught is or on Facebook.
You can't have a relationship.
I know a guy who got his,
his girl looked at his status and his profile and saw he was looking at an ex
girlfriend something and cheating.
She can't him.
If he would have had my history right to look at it,
that wouldn't have been a problem because he was looking at his ex girlfriends
history.
Why wait till you just like,
wow,
this is a crazy bitch.
Got Fat.
How can we can look at that?
That's what it is for kids,
man.
How come we can't do that?
That's ridiculous.
What would it mean?
I don't get that cause I think once in a while you should be allowed to just
check your ex girlfriend.
That makes sir.
Hey,
see what's going on man.
It's no big deal,
dude.
Let,
unless you check your ex girlfriend,
then you get mad at your wife.
Look the fuck you know.
You don't even fucking appreciate me guys
start saying shit like that.
John had fun.
I think we cleared up a lot of things about you today.
Yeah,
for you.
Here's what I'm doing.
I'm not.
I'm going to make you feel good about all this.
I feel good.
I'm going to let it go.
I'm at Saint Louis this week.
Whatever the guidance is in St Louis,
I'm going to bite my lip and not yet where?
Yeah,
it's a funny bone.
The funny bone and Saint Louis.
And what days?
I'm there tomorrow,
which tomorrow?
Thursday the 20th through Sunday.
Oh Shit.
You do the full week?
Huh?
Sunday three shows Saturday,
but I'm moved three shows on Saturday.
No,
I moved the third show Saturday to Sunday.
Double Tion Double Sunday,
so I wouldn't have to,
but then now I'm like,
Oh,
I could've been home Sunday Monday to Friday.
I see.
So instead of double Sunday,
you just have one on Sunday.
I pushed through because then,
yeah,
but you don't want to do,
you're better off doing that because it ain't bad to have that extra day.
And I'll tell you what,
that third show,
his death,
that third Saturday show.
That's too much.
Yeah.
And it's nice.
Not my crowd.
It's okay to go,
you know,
buddies crowd,
maybe Stan hope it's the his crowd for 20 minutes.
When you do what?
You do three shows on Saturday.
It's nobody's crowd after the,
by the time the headliner gets onstage,
it's nobody's crowd that that show is dead.
People are tired manner,
especially on Saturday night,
man,
you've been drinking.
You got the day off.
By the time Saturday night,
if you have a midnight show,
you're not going to show up at midnight.
Man,
you're going to go to a bar first.
You're going to go meet your friends at a bar.
Let's have a couple of beers are you want to get in line?
All right,
let's get in line.
You sit down,
you started ordering more beers.
By the time the show runs around your fucking tired.
I don't think I've ever seen a fight not go down at a midnight show and
especially there.
And that was the last plug that you could smoke St Louis.
Yeah,
it was the last club you can smoke in.
So even up until last year you would show up and it'd be Alaska in the country.
I was still smoking Dallas,
one of the ones I buy.
Right?
That's right.
The last time we were there,
I was making fun of them.
Like how ridiculous that works.
Doesn't it seem like 1970 she's archaic,
especially Dallas Tech.
What I like about Texas is that the,
the whole attitude of Texas,
like get the fuck out.
It's about going to do whatever we want.
It said,
Texas is the shit.
I love Texas.
I was just,
I was like,
if I lived there,
I'd be halfway to every place I got to go.
Yeah.
But the problem is they got some archaic,
we'd laws the we'd love to think about.
So what do you always say that Willie Nelson got arrested?
Okay,
Austin's fucking taking ounces on the road while traveling in a van still
ridiculous.
They pull you over and go looking for it.
Man.
You hear what he got?
His payback was what the court did.
Right.
But that's also because they've got a ton of negative publicity.
There's a ton of people were like the fuck man,
you're,
you're arresting Willie Nelson.
And so the guy said,
look,
his punishment and he has to sing a song.
I'm a huge Willie Nelson Fan,
so that's kind of funny.
That's so,
that's not crazy.
Stils got to go to this guy's fucking courthouse and sing a song.
How about you leave me alone.
How about he doesn't have to sing a song for you for free gangster,
you know,
you fucking asshole.
Some old man wants to feel happy by,
you know,
enjoying a plant that grows naturally.
You [inaudible] you know,
I don't,
I'm not down with those stupid laws.
There's great parts of Texas.
There's like Dallas is bad ass.
I love Houston.
I Love Austin.
Austin.
It would be my number one place to live.
But the problem is those surrounding areas,
man,
they take white trash to a new level,
man.
They got that.
Those black people dragging behind trucks.
White people,
right?
Remember that?
Remember that when that shit happen and those a,
that was some weird fucking little suburb.
There was some weird,
you know,
outline.
I forget what part of Texas that happened.
And do you remember?
No.
But either way,
you know,
there's,
there's a bunch of weird spots,
Waco and all that shit with the branch Davidians went down.
Texas is strange.
And I thought about Nashville cause you're,
you're 30 and literally to every,
and then I'm like,
man,
wait till I ever moved back to Michigan and just,
you know,
get a fucking cold dude.
Yeah.
The winner,
I couldn't get used to.
So it crazy.
Austin,
Texas is the shit the other to me,
yes.
San Diego possible all throughout California and Northern California.
They sent you live a little different area than me and we don't live that far
apart.
Yeah.
I live further out than you.
Yeah,
just by a few miles.
But it's amazing.
It's quiet and it's peaceful.
It is out here to me.
There's too many God damn people.
I feel like I'm in the middle of a beehive.
I'm just as,
especially as I've gotten older and I've smoked more weed,
I become more sensitive to energy.
I've become more sensitive to like what input we can deal with my neighbors.
Your dogs are barking,
really.
I'm not,
you know,
and all that shit.
Yeah.
You're got to deal with a lot of shit,
man.
You have to deal with a lot of shit that's just part of,
of living near a bunch of people and you something about downtime and you and
you're on the road,
you're doing shows,
it's airplanes filled with people and it's airports filled with people and it's
hotels filled with people and it shows filled with people.
And then the downtime when you get home,
it's not necessarily downtime.
And when you have that,
it's like you're,
you're always running at like high rpms.
Like the reason why I moved to the woods and Colorado,
like I had to try to explain this to my wife,
like why I wanted to live there,
why it was great for me.
What I enjoyed about it,
you know,
it's not like I'm crazy.
I'm not ready to go fucking,
you know.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not ready to go a Unabomber.
I'm just saying I liked a little nature in my world.
I need to balance things out.
I like some peace and quiet,
but to her it was like living in that is the whole reality.
You know?
She's not doing shows.
She's not doing the UFC.
You know what I mean?
She's a normal human.
She doesn't,
you know,
so to her it's like maybe this is a little too much isolated and then you deal
with some of those Weirdos and that fucking town.
You know,
if you're going to live with,
you know,
a couple of hundred people in a mountain,
guess what?
Those,
those people are going to be strange as fuck.
You know,
there's some probably some interesting writers.
I lived down the street from an Osh Rom.
There was a real ashram where people would just fuck it meditating all day.
I wasn't,
I was looking into though,
shit you were looking into though.
What are you going to do?
I found out it's a three day,
um,
dongle with magazine.
It's like a three day silence thing where all you do,
it's probably the,
it was in Colorado.
It's probably read days of silence.
You've got to rock three days and no talking about it's impossible for you.
You also have a 10 day one and then,
but it's that you meditate.
I don't know if you're allowed to talk to people at the thing or if it's
completely silent,
silent.
Well,
you know,
I have sleep apnea and I was thinking about getting an operation.
You cannot wear a mouthpiece.
When I go to sleep,
I put a blog up about it on my website and I went to a sleep study.
I have a big tongue,
I have a really fat tongue,
and I have my tonsils and adenoids are still in.
And when I lie back,
my tongue closes over the roof of my mouth with some people that they have,
uh,
issues with.
Um,
some people have issues with sleep apnea because they're fat because you get all
this fat tissue.
And other athletes a lot of times get it because they,
their neck is thick.
And for me,
it's that,
that my neck is thick.
You know,
I lift a lot and then,
you know,
I'm kettlebells and shit,
but also the tongue,
my tongue is like fat.
So what they do is they cut out like some of your mouth tissue and it cut out
your tonsils and your adenoids.
I know this dude.
Um,
uh,
what the fuck's his name?
Mr Gannon gladiator.
Gannett kind of dam and I can't remember his name.
Um,
he,
he had it done and uh,
uh,
he said it helped him a lot,
but if I do it,
the point is I can't talk for 10 days,
like for 10 whole fucking days.
I don't know if that'd be weird.
He'd go crazy if you had a camp though,
for three days where you're just not allowed to that.
Excuse me.
What's that sound?
The background,
ladies and gentlemen.
That sounds enlightenment.
That's what that is.
That's the vaporizers.
Air Conditioning.
Networking.
Is that what it is?
It's hot in here.
What I have to tell you about,
are you?
Hi Jonathan.
Sweating.
But I don't know if it's because a,
I'm having a heart attack or something,
but it's hot in here.
Well,
it also could be the fact that you were drinking coffee,
man.
You know,
it's so hot that water drops going down in the crack of your back and they
actually feels refreshing.
Here we go.
Great.
Yeah,
those feel good.
Correct water.
My chrome browser is taking a shit on me.
You need to get John's blog.
Yeah,
I think I do history rewrite.
I'm just happy they actually had an idea and it through with it and got it done.
Uh,
you know,
I've had 8 billion cure for cancer ideas that I've never really done.
This is the start of a new John Heffron
startup as far as wide internet suffer actually as far as getting shit done.
But again,
shift.
Donna got a script done and I've been really kind of visualizing doing some
stuff to,
you know,
script for a movie.
Yeah.
It's just uh,
it's always something I've always been a free make people read it and please say
no.
Um,
no,
but it was interesting.
I didn't ask any of my friends to do it,
but it's interesting the friends of mine that I've read 8 billion or their
script cost suddenly,
so it's kind of like a test or to see,
okay,
I'm weeding out some of the people in my life that,
that was a good thing.
I haven't asked anybody to read anything of mine really.
For the most part.
That's annoying as fuck,
but I haven't done,
you know what I mean?
I would never go to,
hey,
can you sign it or cause,
but I will.
I mean there's companies that like after we did it that I,
I paid just in,
they give you like script that I don't feel bad about because you paid them to
review it more than my friends.
That's,
yeah,
a lot of that,
you know,
it's like,
it's if boys,
we added,
some guy asked me to read a script once and I'm like,
dude,
you're asking me for an hour and a half of my time.
I don't even know you.
That's a lot of God damn time.
I don't have that much time in a day.
You know?
If you want me to really read it and pay attention to it,
it's an hour and a half.
That's isn't it?
That's a ridiculous question to ask someone.
But how else do you get someone to read your script?
You know,
you've got to get either fuck,
but what do they do a good job?
Like what does it look?
Do you get it back and,
and go fucking look at you.
You want to be great.
You know,
like my stuff,
they review it.
Yeah.
You almost get like a grade and like this part didn't make no sense in you go,
okay.
You know what I mean?
I'll take those notes and blah blah blah.
So I'm getting that done.
Working on a book with the,
uh,
a doctor friend of mine out of Chicago,
a doctor's a shrink.
He's written a lot of books on psychology and comic.
You're,
you're working on a psychology book.
Yeah.
It's like Christie Allie working on a weight loss book,
right?
Yes,
yes.
Um,
but it's uh,
just kind of you,
you have a degree in psychology and have a thing.
Yeah.
Bachelors bs degree when I was going to college,
so I'm doing stuff.
And so what does this book about?
Um,
he's written a lot of books on like Farley and blue and wide comics,
self destruct,
you'd think,
you know what I mean?
And,
and so he also does a lot of cognitive therapy stuff and comics are really good
at reframing shitty situations in their life.
And blowing them so far out of proportion where a lot of people have that
trouble as so when comics are like,
so I just broke up with my girl,
just lost my job.
Some people take stuff so seriously,
they can't see this crazy kind of blown up thing that comics do.
So there's a therapy and psychology that shows people how to do that.
So we've taken parts of my act and you and I talk about how I write and how
everything comes from something shit in my life and how you,
how you kind of get that perspective on.
She's so hot.
Who,
oh,
this is a different one.
This is different than then that doctor,
how are you hanging out with all these doctors?
It was hot doctors.
You know what?
Psychology stuff,
Dr v that
is gorgeous.
You're living a porno film on the tongue.
Dr Tinger got something wrong.
My Dick,
they see,
oh shit.
That's,
so you've got to go out of good shit going on.
People want to get ahold of you.
They go to John heffron.com go John hepburn.com all this stuff.
Two F's,
two F's,
half wrong.com,
and then it has links to everything else.
If you want,
you know,
Lee's book,
Twitter.
Um,
I think I'm on to,
I enjoy Twitter probably more than you know,
and I enjoy Twitter.
I,
my my,
you know,
I'm not,
I don't plug a lot of stuff.
I'd probably 90% reach waiting trying to say some funny and the now in
occasional,
you know,
occasional plugs.
So you respect people's attention span.
So you say funny shit on Twitter all the time.
Yeah.
And um,
you know,
I know,
but I liked that.
I sit there with my tweet deck and I'll click on,
you'll see like I clicked on something you did like about the,
there's no time
for like some of the stuff that you,
yeah,
I retweet a lot of fascinating stuff.
A lot of tightening was fucking amazing.
There's a video of a dude getting hit by lightning twice and then I constantly
clicking.
I don't know what's real.
Brian's cat on his office chair.
I've probably seen,
okay,
this guy just said totally fake.
That's what,
you know,
a lot of people say that,
but I don't know pretty real to me.
But who knows you I totally fake all the,
there's,
there's enough shit that's real.
I mean,
I,
I believe that they would fake enlightening thing.
Yeah,
for sure.
But well,
it's easy to film that.
That's,
that's it.
That was an easy edit.
If like I could reenact that one simple,
right.
Just make the guy fall down and then just make a burn mark cut easy.
It looked good though.
It was just enough.
It's always granny security film,
like,
you know,
stuff like that.
That's true.
You follow Alyssa Milano on Twitter?
Nope.
I don't think so.
I made a B.
I used to,
I weeded out a lot of my Twitter people.
I just get tired of listening to nonsense and that's probably a lot of people.
That'll be,
we'll probably weeded out me too.
But uh,
I uh,
some people will like,
let you know I'm unfollowing Oh,
I got a bunch of people unfollowed me the other day.
This is what I wanted to talk about.
A bunch of people got mad at me,
man,
because I said something about Easter.
This is no bullshit.
I'm going to read this just because it's so fucking silly.
Like this is okay.
I gotta I gotta go back and find it because I couldn't believe that people were
actually getting upset by this.
Um,
but the big thing that people kept saying is that I wasn't being classy because
it was Easter.
You know that it was also gay sex day where you have gay sex.
Can I interject one thing?
Here's one.
Here's one guy says,
okay,
hold on,
let me get the A.
Okay.
See the original tweet.
Okay,
I can't find the original tweet.
Oh,
here it is.
Dear time,
traveling historians in the future trying to make sense of Easter,
let it go and have some chocolate and no one understands it.
That's all I said.
Let it go and have some chocolate to time traveling and story.
Nothing.
Right?
And so I hear not cool man,
making fun of Cra Christ and Christians on the holiest of days.
Can't you leave?
You can't leave it alone.
Can you,
and I'm a fan of yours.
Wow.
Like,
like whoa.
So I quote,
so I tweet all you silly fucks that are actually upset at someone is making fun
of zombies and giant rabbits.
You need mushrooms in your life.
So,
and then I get just attack after attack.
People attacking me for retweeting him.
Yeah.
Leave him out there so your fans and quotes can attack.
You know this other fan and I was like,
I didn't tell people what to say about this.
I didn't tell you.
I just want to,
I just want you to see the kind of craziness that I get when I say dear time
traveling historians don't try to figure out east or just have some chocolate
like that offends you.
And a bunch of people like a,
doesn't use the word classy.
Like yeah,
we'll see classy making fun of Christ on Easter.
Like,
well I'm not making
fun.
I'm going to
see the most shit in the world.
Well,
the gimme names are so focused on all the negative and they're supposed to be
religious with the people that were doing this all had this one hashtag in their
sentence.
He is risen in quotes.
He is risen like,
like a bone or what?
No,
no.
Like a boner.
But that would be fun to take it.
The reason for the gay sexiest day ever.
Yeah,
I'm into my cave.
Yeah.
Let me move this rock for risen.
Can I just randomly,
I just got a tweet.
Somebody,
you know,
we were talking about my thing in some kid goes,
uh,
says,
okay,
this song's tool.
But what about private browsing?
Every browser has it.
Sorry.
Dumb idea.
Can I say some?
Yeah.
Every browser has private browsing.
But the deal is when you hit that you have zero in your Internet history.
No,
no,
no.
What private browsing it also does is it also just stops anything you're doing,
but you have to constantly mind been there.
Turn it on,
turn off an alibi.
Right.
So if you're on the Internet for two hours,
you're not going to have zero Internet.
Right.
And it's going to say use young kids and want married.
I have no idea what kind of level.
Sorry,
I do that.
That is a really ridiculous thing to have to worry about,
isn't it?
You're not allowed to look at things.
I don't trust you yet.
What are you crazy?
What are you out there looking at what you're interested in?
I want you to keep your mind in line with my feelings.
That's why I like
the sweatshirt.
You like girls that look at worship than,
yeah,
that girls that like their browser.
Internet history is way more shocking than mine.
He came home and you'd girl was masturbating to gay porn.
She does all the time.
No,
God,
gay gay porn is not girls going at it,
going at it.
It's just porn.
It's his girl on girl porn and gay porn.
What would you do if you came home to one dude?
It's just fucking some guy and she's fingering herself.
She thinks it's hot.
I would just start struck and my shaft and you're so close.
You're so gross.
There's something.
Would you be looking at [inaudible] my shaft of my,
please don't.
It'd be classy.
Classy,
classy.
So some people can say things and they say it a certain way or in the same
words,
right?
You lose a lot in texts,
you know,
until you really do,
I mean,
if you're reading a script for a porno and the guy was trying to fuck his wife
on the ass and is,
and it says,
you want to put in my ass,
oh my God,
we can't know there's,
that's,
that's just unscript you know,
just written.
But you could have it two different ways.
Like I'm going to put it my ass.
Oh my God.
No.
Like that girl wants a dick in her ass.
All right.
That's all the tone.
The tone or it can be,
you want to put it in my ass.
Watch.
No,
we can't.
that's an angry girl.
She's angry
by the way.
Nothing fucks up dudes more for the rest of their life then.
Then porn or they have anal sex because it always goes well.
And there's never fucking complaints.
No one's ever angry,
you know?
But when you bought fuck someone,
nine times out of 10 you go say sorry afterwards.
You know,
like,
I didn't know what you should've told me.
Your ass is not meant to be fucked.
You know what I learned is a few,
I have a finger in the girl's ass and then don't put it like take it out and put
it in her vagina.
You didn't know that he'd dummy.
Didn't ever think about,
oh my God.
Did you give her a crazy funky and no,
she's making little shit babies.
I don't finger a lot of girls in the ass,
so I've only done a couple of times.
I've never really thought like,
oh yeah,
it's not a good idea.
Yay.
Yeah,
yeah.
A lot of people right now shutting off their fucking iPod.
We were good for about two hours and then finally to show all this Easter toast,
fucking morons.
Bob was headlining and I was in the back right now by the sound guy.
I'm like,
can we like him?
Can we please?
What's he doing?
He's trained in my crowd.
He's making my crowd dumb.
I love,
by the way,
all the comments that I have a um,
some kind of social disorder.
You do.
You really think I do.
You know me well,
you know how like how you know how I act on this show?
It's completely,
Brian is a unusual dude.
Okay.
Nobody,
everybody's different.
You don't have to be around peg or a square hole,
right?
We're all different.
He's,
he's,
he's unusual.
It's kind of bad.
Pimp skills.
Give him some knuckles.
Oh,
does the best with the stories that make me get these girls here.
He's like,
I'm a retard and people feel bad for retards.
So they start like slowly like combing my hair and then they find out what it
is.
Do you feel a little retarded though?
I'll be honest.
I overdo retard on this.
Definitely.
It's almost like you're half playing a character.
I am half plank care.
I'm red band man.
I'm not.
Brian was Shelly.
Oh by the way,
he talked about yourself in the third person.
Well,
we talking to girls on the phone.
red band does.
Red Wants to do,
I did as a joke.
Definitely.
You don't do it.
I never see her last sanction.
Sometimes when I see you on Facebook and I'll see your full name,
my brain doesn't connect.
Right?
So I will click on your thing.
Your profile will come up.
I'll see the picture of you.
Then I'll go yo,
like I,
that's my process.
Yeah.
There's nothing Brian,
your your name and I can never even know.
You know,
there's some people that you just think of their like,
like one of the dudes from,
uh,
from the tap out crew.
His name's Tim,
right?
But I call him scrape cause he's always scrape.
So if I see Tim written somewhere on the fucking him like,
oh yeah,
was kind of name.
It's not just scrape.
You know,
I gotta stop doing that Facebook chat and let people talk.
It's just a waste of my time.
This is what we need to do.
No,
we need to get you both podcast.
Fill it with,
do a podcast.
It'll be the greatest thing for,
look,
your whole thing is you don't have to be by yourself.
You look best squad,
extra hundred bucks every week and take some fucking kid was you on the road?
Come to do podcasts with him.
He's coming to death squad once a week.
Come on.
How many,
how many funny young comics are there at the Improv that would love to go and
open for you.
Pay Him a hundred bucks or sad or 150 bucks a set or whatever the fuck you want
to pay him.
You know,
and and,
and you know it's going to cost you a little bit more money but you're going to
have a much better experience and you could put together a podcast and do
whatever.
Yeah,
to it after the shows easily man,
you can interview all kinds of people.
You can.
There's always interesting like how many times you talked to club owners and
they have some crazy ass fucking comedy stories of the onetime,
Tracy Morgan came through town and I hear stories about some of these guys be
total dicks to the club owners.
Go,
really?
You're allowed to say that stuff here.
I,
you know what I mean?
I'm,
I'm sitting in the corner guard.
Do you guys mind?
Can I get some water?
And then you hear the next story of somebody who was in there going,
yeah,
he got two waitresses pregnant,
but we don't care cause he sold out the place you do to be great.
A podcast where you're talking to the opening comic but you're telling them what
you're doing wrong for an hour
and you sit down,
let's go,
let's move your real job.
How's everybody doing tonight?
Do you really want to ask that question?
This is what you want to Sheldon,
you want to tell these people how they're doing?
We're at the fucking John Hamm Fun show.
Awesome.
That would be a great podcast.
Then quit selling cds with the sharp re and no sticker on your cds.
No sticker on the CDS.
That'd be over emotional podcast for real though.
Like you do it seriously like you're playing a character almost.
What did you just say about sharpies?
Explain yourself.
You just,
what did the first guys that sell stuff that are like MCS that'll grab like a
blank CD and they get with the Sharpie,
write their name on it and then the cell,
their act after a show but not even produce cds.
I'm confused.
They sell blank CD?
No,
they'll like put their computer,
the burn,
the burn to see your act and then with the sharpie write their name and then
that's what they sell to.
People have to have show.
Do you mind if I sell something?
I would buy that if I was a fan.
Oh,
hold on.
Sorry.
Yeah.
What do you think about that?
I let them,
I 100% let them,
but I also,
but then I metal,
I go,
this is the last image you want for for 80 cents you can make a prepackage cool
thing to give them.
So you look professional and they're like,
well that costs money.
Is this a recording of the show?
They just did.
No,
this is like they had already made
one.
They made it.
But I think it's a good idea is after you get off there to show you sell a a
pass that in the next week you're going to go to a website and you can download
the seat that tonight's show.
You can download the whole thing immediately.
There's a guy that I made with that I asked him,
I go,
can you shoot this one little clip of my act?
I wanna I wanna use it for something in a camera.
And then he shot it and put it up on Youtube.
How pissed would you be?
Pretty pissed if I said,
can I use your camera for a second?
Brian can,
can you just shoot my set?
And he goes,
yeah.
And then that,
that night without you saying anything,
he puts it on Youtube.
Yeah.
Wow.
Someone did that to you?
Yeah.
Wow.
Did you get youtube to take it down?
No cause I ended up thing,
but I think he did it from a place of I'm going to help him out cause he said he
wanted it for the Internet.
So I didn't
he,
I think it was unaware he was going to film it for the Internet.
No,
I said it's for my history rear rewrite.
I go,
I'm going to talk about this browser on stage.
I just want to get this thing,
then I'm going to use it.
Right.
So then he shoots,
he shoots it and then it puts the whole set online and then he put the thing on
youtube.
So I'll set,
um,
a lot of it,
not the,
but,
but I wanted the,
the hard drive and then I was gonna put it on my computer and whatever,
but he put it on youtube and I was like,
hmm.
And you didn't,
what did you say to him?
I go,
Hey,
I appreciate you did this,
but I didn't want to get this internet.
What?
Because he came from a place of being helpful.
I'm not confrontational,
but I'm like,
maybe she got,
now I'm second guessing.
I'm like,
am I being a Dick for being?
He should have had that to me is the most private of of things.
That's not cool.
There's a reason why every club says don't use cameras.
You know it's supposed to film and it's because you,
if you get a guys act as if it already gets out there on the Internet,
maybe you don't want to go see him then you know maybe always got the same.
He,
this was last week,
I already saw his jokes,
I saw him on Youtube.
People do that.
People Watch everything of yours now before they come and see you.
And look,
that's a valid reason for not going to a show.
I'll tell you,
if you go to see someone,
I mean look if,
if,
if I was a kid and I only had a certain amount of money and I liked the comment
cause I watched this clip on youtube and it was his whole act and was broken
down into six clips and I watched all of them and then he's going to be in my
town.
Well that's the way a week ago.
What are the odds?
He's got new material and he's awesome,
but I'm not going to go.
Yeah,
it'll,
you know,
people less people will see you,
the show,
you know,
like you,
Stan hope gets really mad.
He's even got a big,
uh,
a bit about it,
a bit about telling people to stop doing stop filming shows while it's going on.
But it's also a part of the,
it's part of the Internet.
I mean people are going to get clips off your phone,
you know,
off their phones and shit like that.
But there's a big difference between that,
like some sneaky audience members just trying to have some fun and some asshole
that films you and then doesn't tell you and then puts it online.
It puts it,
he's just trying to get hits on is a huge showing another comic that seems like
he's another comic.
He was the MC Tom breaking like every kind of guy code or comic code that you
could add.
Slap a bitch and he just think you weren't going to know.
Did he bring it up or did you find uh,
I went into the green room and the clip was on youtube on his channel and I'm
like,
is that me on his,
and then the other comment goes,
yeah man,
he put that up there.
I was like,
how many minutes did he put up?
It was just,
it was really short.
It was only like three f three,
because I wanted it for,
to promote the browser.
So it wasn't my whole act.
But the fact that your whole act,
was it the clip to promote the browser that he put on Lauren?
What did you put 'em on the clip to promote the book.
But I didn't tell him what clip I won and I kind of said to me that's kind of
pointless.
It's regardless.
So through the,
I'm so confused.
I thought he puts your whole act online so he only put like
a couple of minutes.
You put a couple of minutes and it gets,
you shouldn't have put anything online.
And it was the clip that I said I want it to use on that.
Not nearly as offensive.
It's putting,
I thought,
wow,
I'm so stoned.
Cause that's what I was thinking too.
And this whole time I'm down just like you social disorder.
Yeah.
This is,
this whole podcast is a fucking intervention.
Um,
so John had fun.
When are you going to start doing a desk squad podcast.
Why don't you get,
get on the fucking program?
I'm gone this week.
I'm home all next.
[inaudible] start it next week.
This is what would you have this much equipment underneath my desk in shoe boxes
is what we'll do it together.
Rag Tag or just go to Brian's house.
We'll uh,
we'll make sure that we mention it on the podcast so that people could download
it when you actually do want of doing it and we'll put it on Twitter.
But I think it's the perfect solution for you.
I mean,
nobody's more miserable than you when you go on the road.
You know what I'm saying?
We,
whenever we talk,
you always talking about,
I've been on the road for 18 months.
I'm miserable.
I ever,
you know what I mean?
Just have one other thing to do and that other thing people would love.
It's like another,
it's an opportunity to do another show.
You know what to do.
Do a little radio show a little John half run on the road,
do it from hotel rooms.
That's your hook.
You're doing it on the road from hotel rooms and maybe you know if you're in
Cleveland and there's two clubs in Cleveland,
maybe you can call the guy was at the other club and he can meet you after a
Friday night show and that's what you guys can do.
And you smoke a joint and fucking do the only thing come on site and I can
travel with us.
Bitches do.
It was thinking in advance,
setting up John have fun and free entertainment from my people.
Now I need a name
now stuff cobb's in San Francisco is the next club we're doing.
And that is Thursday,
Friday and Saturday the 12th,
13th,
and 14th.
And as I said,
the last podcast,
well as of a couple of days ago,
half the tickets were already sold out and I just started talking about it and
the vogue theater,
which is,
um,
June,
June 10th,
uh,
and that's in Vancouver and that the tickets just went on sale and half of those
tickets are sold out too.
So I don't want any you bitches getting left out in the cold.
Um,
in,
uh,
Toronto Friday night it's going to be Sam Tripoli and me.
So,
uh,
that should be fun as fuck.
I can't wait.
It's at Massey Hall.
Most of the tickets are sold out.
The only thing that's left is like single tickets.
So I think there's like a hundred single tickets left and then the halls.
Great too.
You did it.
Have you done it yet?
Last summer?
What'd you do it with?
Just for laughs mean brewer.
Oh,
nice.
Yeah.
Is it,
is it beautiful?
Yeah.
Nice.
I love Toronto.
I can't fucking wait.
UFC fucking 55,000 people going to be this weekend.
That's going to be nuts.
Biggest in North American history that Saturday night.
George Saint Pierre Versus Jake.
She owns good.
I want to apologize the lady bug seven from my Twitter remarks.
Remarks today.
Yeah.
Explain what you did.
You fucked up how she wrote a really weird sentence that said something like,
uh,
you know,
please retweet if he don't think red ban is a Douche.
And I thought it said,
please retweet if you think red bands.
And Dude,
she was like one of iPhone.
Like you're
looking in the car while you're driving down the highway.
And so I retreated back.
Something rude and I apologize.
Okay.
You tweeted back some roots.
I personally attacked her.
You personally,
it's something I'd never do on Twitter.
I was just like,
oh,
I got a funny joke that I'm a PR.
It was like more of a joke that I was just like,
oh,
I could do this joke that I wrote,
but it was mean.
It would mean,
and it was,
you fucked up.
I fucked up and I feel bad.
So look at that.
You guys give her,
you're making amends.
What's her Twitter name or a Twitter names lady bug seven lady bugs seven.
Now what's going to your enemies will now coopt her term.
What they'll do is they'll be nice to lady bugs Chava and they're gonna do,
we're going to slowly but surely gain her confidence.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
I'll read her tweets and lol them.
You know our t with an lol just to let them know like,
wow,
this girl's really,
she's really happy.
She's saying some smart shit.
Then then one day,
I just think what that red band guy did to you was really fucked up.
You went to the olive garden with me.
Then let's get back now let's get back at that.
Fuck
all you Easter bitches.
Let it go.
Okay.
And UFC,
we're going to be doing the drinking game with you,
Joe.
So try to remember to do that.
And if I'm not,
if I,
I might go fish.
If I see drinking games,
this is one shot.
And if I say that when a fighter is walking out,
that means Kohlberg's Ping and we're going to do UFC drunk cast,
I believe with Dheas and they'll post.
It was next to me.
Remember,
remind me that,
remind me that.
Oh,
there was one other thing that I forgot to talk about.
They shut down Seti.
They shut down the search for extraterrestrial intelligence budget cuts.
They shut that thing down.
Those,
uh,
from contact.
Remember the movie contact with Jodie Foster?
I just saw that like a couple of weeks ago.
Fucking great movie man still holds up bad ass movie.
And that was about them receiving signals from another galaxy.
And the signals were directions on how to build some wormhole machine and you
know,
you jump through it and fly through this wormhole and communicate with alien
life and on the ship.
Interesting fucking movie.
One of my favorites.
But uh,
they,
uh,
they shut down the program and the reason why they shut it down,
it's because they've had no success.
You know,
if all this listening,
all this listening,
all this listening now,
who the fuck would have thought,
why would you think to do it's still be using radio.
Yeah.
Right.
If they're smart enough to be,
you know,
they can,
they can travel from here to from other galaxies to here.
Why the fuck would they still be using,
raise it that they're going to be some new cool shit.
Is it that they're doing radio or that it would be changes in signal?
Well,
it's in,
it's any kind of a broadcast and he signaled,
that comes from,
you know,
they're looking at a bunch of different bandwidths.
They're looking at any kind of signal.
I mean,
that's why they get,
they get,
um,
like,
uh,
planets give off signals.
So novas hyper Novas they give off signals and all sorts of different things
give off signals.
They're just trying to look for a pattern and trying to look for something
that's,
that seems to be some sort of a message.
But it's really,
it's kind of a flawed idea.
I think it's been around forever and they've really never had any progress.
You mean there's,
I mean,
they just waiting and waiting and waiting and waiting and waiting and waiting
and hoping that if there,
if they can contact us,
they're going to fucking contact us.
You know?
I think it's going to happen where I think if there was alien life,
I think they would easily be able to get to us before we would ever be able to
detect them.
They would want to check us out.
You know,
if you,
if you live near some planet and you had these halfway evolved monkeys with
nuclear weapons,
you wouldn't want to keep an eye on those crazy motherfuckers.
What do you think that they're smarter than us and you're going to give it like
what if the human race,
it's amazing and they're all just let rolling around in circles like peeing on
themselves.
Well,
that's true,
but if that's true,
they're not coming here anyway,
then you don't have to worry about signals.
You don't have to worry about anything.
I mean,
it could very well be that we are the apex of intelligent life in the universe.
It's very possible.
It could be that that human life,
you know,
or life intelligent life,
any kind of light,
it's really,
really,
really hard to develop it.
I mean,
it takes the absolute perfect conditions and this weird planet just happens to
be a certain distance from the soil.
The start of it,
one day we'll get smart enough to go do have land and we have a large moons or
orbit is stable.
You know,
that's the other thing we don't,
it doesn't vary much between summer and winter.
There they're pretty small degrees of variations compared to some planets.
So like we're in the,
the ideal conditions.
It very well could be that this is as good as it gets.
But it's also possible that the universe is,
you know,
at least 14 billion years old and this planet is only like 4.6 billion or
something like that.
So that leaves out somewhere between nine and 10 billion fucking years for one
planet to evolve past the point that we have.
And if that is possible for something,
I mean who knows,
because if it is,
it comes into question like how long the stars last?
What of the star Burns out while the civilizations evolving?
Is it a big race?
Cause it's our,
our son is eventually going to burn out.
So on one hand,
the,
if the human race is going to survive,
it has to figure out a way to colonize space.
It's the only way to do it.
I mean,
if we're going to stay around and to,
any life is going to stay around in a few billion years.
I mean [inaudible] I mean now I don't know how many billion it takes,
but let's just assume that if wife has been around for 4 billion years,
whatever the fuck it's been,
however long the life has been around it,
which assume a billion years from now,
it's probably still going to be life.
Right?
Would,
if that's when the stunts starts going bad,
if it's 2 billion or three,
but whatever the fuck it is,
eventually,
if life keeps going,
we're going to have to get off this fucking thing.
Oh,
there will be no more life.
You know,
it's really that simple.
So if there is some sort of a life,
a of some sort of a civilization,
some sort of an intelligent civilization that is a billion years older than us,
they know about us,
you know,
I don't know if they do.
I,
I'm not convinced.
I watch all those Ufo footages,
man,
and I just,
I just feel like I'm being fucked with,
you know,
I watched that.
The mode,
the recent one from Jerusalem,
a million people twittered me that thing.
It looks fake as fuck you.
You seen that the one in Israel Ufo over Israel?
No,
I don't want the one that just shoots straight up.
Yeah,
we,
yeah.
We talked about from a couple of weeks that we talked about it isn't that you
said it's an effect that's an effect,
an after effects.
It's,
yeah.
That was already proven to be fake.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on man.
Haven't seen one.
I haven't seen one where I'm like,
wow,
what the fuck is that?
I haven't seen one.
You know,
everybody's got a goddamn camera on their cell phone.
There's pictures of the guy from Seinfeld yelling nigger on stage.
There's video of that.
What are the odds you're there with when that happens and you have a camera,
right?
You know there's that.
How often does that happen?
That might have never happened ever again.
And the whole universe,
right?
Kramer from Seinfeld yelling nigger on stage at the laugh factory and someone
got a video at,
right?
You're telling me they don't have one video of one fucking alien,
one video of one little gray man and your room.
That's realistic to me.
One video,
a full hunters.
What we picked up again next season that I sit in the hotels,
go shows to go shows are my favorite.
Who were in the basement.
What does that noise cut to?
Commercial.
You know,
nothing ever happens.
Nothing happens on those go shows.
Those are the most unsatisfying shows ever,
but they're huge.
Those things do real well.
There's like 80 ghost hunter shows and they dress up like,
yeah,
they dress up with like fucking military garb and shit with powerful fucking
flashlights and shit and looking for ghosts in a basement of a building.
Get out of their stupid.
That's my message.
Get out of their stupid really
cool show on history channel that just started.
I haven't heard anything about the,
the history,
the,
the 80s technology,
the history of the 80s technology and I guess it's really cool like one episode
they dissected like you arcade games back in the early eighties and like the
technology and then they started moving onto all that's bad at yeah,
it's like a tare and yeah.
Yeah.
Like so then I started last night and one of those where you're just on the
internet in a daze,
like a Zombie going through everything,
looking at old arcade games for sale on a like a craigslist and shit.
If you ever thought about just making an arcade room,
like an old school arcade room around the pool table.
I liked pool better than any games.
The more I played pool,
the more I like it.
A pool is to me way more fun than Arcade Games.
If I had a pool table next to an arcade,
I don't want to play stupid video.
Hadn't tron reach somebody to spit and read cool on paper,
but it's like driving an old car.
Adam Carolla.
What we were talking about old cars yesterday.
Like you have an old hot rod,
they're really like a conversation piece.
You sit around and you'll look at it because driving is kind of stupid.
Right.
You know,
and that's kind of how those games are kind of cool.
Oh,
that's the old tron.
Well,
yeah.
Why would you play that when you can play gears of war.
True.
By the way,
stupid cliffy be in June.
Just a,
he's going to come out here with e three and he's going to be on the podcast.
Yes.
Coffee Bean is going to be on the podcast.
May 11th.
Doug Benson is going to be on the podcast and Dunkin was supposed to be here
today,
but Dunkin's got a new show that he's putting together himself.
So he's responsible for all the editing and he had a work through the night and
he was just way too tired.
So He's been up all night.
So Dunkin is going to come back on Monday and if anybody wants to see John Half
Ron,
I highly recommend it.
He's fucking hilarious and uh,
always has new shit till you turn over your material a lot.
A lot because my brain forgets stuff.
That's why you're always writing.
So your,
you've got a great work ethic when it comes to that.
I W I appreciate that man.
We were talking on the podcast yesterday about c k and that,
uh,
that new show,
talking funny that they did for Hbo,
which is awesome for that too.
Just talking about writing a lot of material.
All right.
Um,
so John [inaudible] dot com that's with two F's.
If you want to check out John and John on Twitter is John Half.
Ron and you will be appearing at,
I'm in St Louis,
the funny bone now this week.
St Louis,
funny bone Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday bitches.
It's a full ride.
Go check it out.
I highly recommended and a check out the death squads series,
a podcast also that are on iTunes and that is what a half Ron will debut on.
And a Ari Shaffir has his podcast over there.
Sam Triple,
he has his podcast over there and uh,
Brian runs the whole thing.
It's a bunch of different funny people.
Tom [inaudible] and his wife Christine have a podcast on there.
So it's a,
it's a,
it's a cool thing.
It's a,
it's a nice network of you can always be assured that you're going to have
something interesting,
cool to listen to and we're going to have half run on.
What's to give me the name of the half Ron podcast.
Quickly,
quickly overthinking first idea of Golder.
I like overthinking,
overthinking,
which I have.
Fuck,
boom.
We got it.
That's it.
Overthinking with John headphone will debut very soon.
Thank you.
Love you bitches.
Podcasts on a plane with Sam trevally company soon.
Yeah.
Awesome.
This last slide.
Oh,
thanks.
The fresh light.
You dirty bitches.
You get 15% off and the go to Joe rogan.net and her in the code day,
Brogan and um,
and you get 15% off the number one sex toy from mental.
All trash talk.
They're you.
Oh ha ha ha.
I one's the best boy.
Brian likes to DoubleClick experience.
Holla at you,
boy bitches.
Thank you very much for everything.
I love you guys.
Thank you.
The Joe Rogan experience,
the Joe Rogan experience,
the Joe Rogan experience.